Mobile Task Force Edna-84, also known by the
code name “And Thus Upon His Crucible”,
is on one of the strangest missions they’ve
ever been sent on.
They sit in a darkened room, beads of sweat
trickling down their brows.
The lights of computer monitors shine up into
their faces.
They’re tackling a monster that, if it escapes,
will literally devour all of creation.
It has no fear, it has no remorse, and if
it isn’t kept contained by Edna-84, it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world.
Oh, and did we mention it’s trapped inside
a Minecraft server?
You heard us right: SCP-4335 is a cognitohazardous,
extradimensional being of pure terror, trapped
inside a procedurally generated world in the
immensely popular game Minecraft.
You hear about a lot of horrifying monsters
being described as Lovecraftian, but only
this monster is Minecraftian.
There’s a lot that needs explaining here,
and we intend to get to all of it, but let’s
start with how the Foundation keeps this truly
exceptional beast contained.
The Foundation first discovered SCP-4335 back
in 2010, shortly after the Alpha Version of
Minecraft was released.
Because of the online nature of the game,
it’s proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally, seeing as it isn’t confined
to any one physical location.
Shutting off the server 4335 is found in is
not an effective containment method either,
as this just causes the entity to simply hop
to a different server.
The Foundation’s greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of Minecraft
and cause chaos in our world.
That’s why it’s imperative to draft Containment
Procedures for SCP-4335 within the game.
This led to the creation of a containment
site unlike any other: Site-M1, the first
official Foundation Site made entirely out
of Minecraft blocks.
Everyone who was originally involved in the
server has been removed and amnesthetized.
Since then, elite SCP Foundation Containment
Specialists and Gamers have been constructing
the perfect prison for SCP-4335.
Site-M1 is a large, stone complex built into
the side of a mountain.
It has a number of key features - including
a supply area filled with materials vital
for 4335’s continued containment.
Chests filled with books that contain SCP-4335's
containment procedures.
A few animal farms, for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat.
The entrance to a mine.
Several chests containing books specifically
designed for civilians to learn about 4335,
if they ever breach containment and enter
the server.
And of course, the actual containment chamber
for SCP-4335 itself, which is a little more
complicated.
4335’s containment chamber is built out
of several layers, all made from iron blocks.
The outermost cube is 75 x 75 x 75 blocks,
the inner cube is 55 x 55 x 55 blocks, and
the innermost cube is 25 x 25 x 25 blocks,
creating several levels of defense.
Finally one layer within all these others,
which contains the anomaly proper, is made
from obsidian blocks.
SCP-4335 is bound into the center of the containment
chamber with a complex mechanism.
The outermost cube is completely filled with
water, and several dispensers capable of rapidly
dispensing large amounts of items in a short
amount of time line the cube.
The cube also contains several mob farms,
which are devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when they
die.
The chamber is essentially designed to funnel
a constant flow of items inwards to SCP-4335.
There are even contingency measures for if
SCP-4335 manages to breach containment.
If escape is attempted, blocks of TNT detonate
above the ceiling, causing lava to pour into
the chamber.
At that point, MTF Edna-84 are dispatched
into the server to lure 4335 back into its
containment chamber.
To do this, they use a mix of fire-resistance
potions and Ender Pearls - which have teleportation
capabilities.
Interestingly, there’s one more basic method
of luring SCP-4335 back into the obsidian
cube: Taunting and insulting.
One of SCP-4335’s many anomalous abilities
is being able to hear people through the screen,
and - being a proud creature - it often responds
to insults by charging in to directly engage
the insulter.
If SCP-4335 still manages to breach the containment
that has been set up for it, then they expect
that it will likely soon hop into another
server.
At that point, the goal will shift to finding
the monster and recontaining it.
With Containment Procedures this complex and
extensive, it shouldn’t come as a surprise
that SCP-4335 rests firmly in the Keter Class.
What exactly is this anomalous entity?
Why does its containment hinge on constantly
providing it with items?
And how did it end up in Mojang’s popular
building and survival game in the first place?
SCP-4335, in terms of physical dimensions,
appears almost identical to the player character,
with an all-black skin.
It also appears to be constantly shrouded
in a cloud of smoke particles, and has long,
black tendrils protruding from its back.
In some respects, 4335 has been compared to
two popular creepypasta figures: Herobrine
and The Slenderman.
But 4335 is far stranger.
Its physical body behaves similarly to most
assets native to the game, with a few peculiar
anomalous abilities we’ll discuss soon.
Handling SCP-4335 is an extremely delicate
process.
If command blocks, creative mode, or server
commands are ever enabled in a server with
SCP-4335, the server will instantly shut down,
and SCP-4335 will move to a different server.
SCP-4335 also uses its tendrils to destroy
surrounding blocks before consuming them.
With each successful consumption, SCP-4335
grows, and when it reaches sufficient size,
it hops to a different server.
As you can see, keeping SCP-4335 contained
is an uphill battle, but luckily there are
two factors on the Foundation’s side here.
The first is that SCP-4335 is immobilized
while consuming items and blocks, limiting
its ability to actively escape Foundation
forces.
The second factor is that SCP-4335 needs a
rest period between consuming blocks in order
to grow, meaning, if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn’t able to grow.
These two factors have informed the entirety
of the Foundation’s Containment Procedures
around SCP-4335: It’s locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly, effectively
rooting it in place.
When SCP-4335 begins to grow, the Foundation
also found that the application of Ender Pearls
helps reduce it back to its normal size.
However, SCP-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors.
4335 is Vurgent-class multi-sensory cognitohazard.
Anyone viewing it without proper training
and protection may experience distressing
hallucinations.
SCP-4335 is also capable of telepathic speech
with people playing on its server, and - as
we alluded to earlier - it can also hear any
noises you make while playing.
“Weird” is a term thrown around a lot
when it comes to SCPs, considering it’s
pretty much a requirement for the Foundation
to take interest in you.
But an all-devouring Minecraft demon that
can hear you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards.
MTF Edna-84 first discovered SCP-4335 in the
single-player server of Minecraft user Leakingheart.
Three team members - Jason Yelsan, Richard
Duchamp, and Sheila Freemason - covertly entered
the game to investigate and potentially apprehend
the creature.
When Leakingheart first discovered their presence
on what he thought was a private server, he
quickly left, a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion.
Thankfully, the trio was still able to locate
SCP-4335.
They discovered the creature hiding inside
a giant crater, as though it had impacted
the earth at considerable speed.
Richard Duchamp, who was the leader of the
team at the time, made the mistake of looking
directly at the entity.
In that moment, he experienced the full force
of SCP-4335’s cognitohazardous effects.
He hallucinated, believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes.
In the aftermath of this incident, Duchamp
was taken off the case, and Jason Yelsan was
promoted to head of the project.
Things were still going to get stranger.
Yelsan was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a chamber
filled with lava.
It asked him whether it had landed in the
right location - meaning, our world - and
Yelsan informed it that it’d somehow fallen
into the world of Minecraft instead.
The creature was at first confused, and then
angry and resentful about its situation.
It vowed to find its way into our world somehow,
and obtain more “sustenance.”
A few months after this, the entity managed
to breach containment and hop into another
server.
Yelsan and two others once again managed to
track it down and recontain it, but this time,
two civilians also inhabiting the server were
exposed to the anomalous effects of SCP-4335.
They weren’t hurt, but they did appear strange
and incoherent after experiencing 4335’s
cognitohazards.
The Foundation tracked them down in the aftermath
and gave them amnestic treatment.
4335 was contained shortly thereafter.
Once again, Yelsan came face to face with
his new foe.
Eight months after being captured, 4335 granted
Yelsan another interview from containment.
4335 admitted that it almost respected Yelsan
and the rest of the Foundation for figuring
out how to capture and contain it so quickly.
In exchange, it would give the Foundation
something extremely valuable: Information.
First, it asked one question of Yelsan: How
does he define “creation?”
Yelsan replied, “Uh… something that is
built and brought to this universe by a sapient
being, using other things from this universe?”
4335 agreed.
It went on to explain that it came from a
universe devoid of creation.
A dark and unknowable place, filled with nothing
but violent, random chaos.
Its dimension existed directly above ours,
and it often looked down at us through a dimensional
window, fascinated by all the creation below.
It plotted and dreamed to one day infiltrate
our reality, and Yelsan finally had the opportunity
to ask the magic question, “Why?”
Though he wasn’t quite ready for the brutal
honesty of SCP-4335’s reply.
“I do not like to lie, so I will tell you
now.
I wish to suck it dry of the toys of whatever
force controls your universe.
Destroy the light, destroy the Earth, and
destroy humanity.
It reminded me… of me.
A blubbering mass of intelligence and order.
It sickens me in ways I cannot comprehend.
I hope you understand.”
SCP-4335 was a connoisseur of creation, and
it sought to devour all of it.
In this moment, Yelsan realized what an incredibly
dangerous entity he was dealing with.
The only mystery was why this creature had
somehow landed in Minecraft instead of our
world, which appeared to be the only thing
that saved us.
But Yelsan didn’t have time to think: 4335
was about to stage another daring escape attempt.
One of its tendrils reached out and attacked
Yelsan’s player character.
In that moment, the real life Yelsan began
to hallucinate and panic.
Suddenly, back in the game, a series of abnormally
tall, slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber around
SCP-4335.
It had somehow summoned new minions into the
game to assist in this containment breach.
Jason Yelsan entered cognitohazard quarantine
following this incident, and was removed from
the project.
And he wasn’t the only one affected by this
incident.
Following the first appearance of these long,
dark figures, players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their own
games.
The Foundation managed to find a solution:
They contacted Mojang and had the creatures
patched into the game during the next update,
as a new non-anomalous entity, which seemed
to stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools.
They’re now known as the Endermen, and are
beloved among fans for being one of the creepier
enemies.
To this day, containment efforts continue
for SCP-4335.
There’s only one question left: Why did
the entity fall into Minecraft rather than
our world?
The file posits the most likely answer.
Because 4335 defines creation as elements
made by sapient beings.
In Minecraft, the most popular game in the
world at the height of 4335’s power, everything
that exists is the product of code made by
humans.
Creation is truly abundant there.
As for our world, in SCP-4335’s extra-dimensional
eyes, there is no creation, no intelligent
design, no soothing piano soundtrack.
Just frightening, chaotic, randomness, which
is too unlike its own dimension.
So even if SCP-4335 ever did arrive in our
reality, it would likely be disappointed by
how little there is to eat.
You’re sitting in the middle of a cheering
crowd.
The arena around you is electric, fans hollering
from their seats as they watch the basketball
game.
Every point scored, every shot missed, and
every skillful pass of the ball sends waves
of excitement over everyone in the audience.
Applause, shouts, and chants fill the air.
It distracts you for a moment, you find yourself
swept up in the energy of the game.
But slowly, surely, a nagging feeling creeps
up on you as your eyes follow the ball.
That feeling turns to a sickening realization
as one of the players jumps and dunks the
basketball, scoring another two points.
You notice the look on his face, the same
look on the faces of all the other players
on the court: a solemn, hopeless expression.
It’s the same look of silent despair worn
by all the spectators around you.
Then you remember, you’ve watched this exact
game of basketball before.
Many, many times before.
And that is when you feel the same hopeless
expression appear on your own face, realizing
just how long you have been here, watching
this game over and over.
Reminded that you will never, ever leave this
arena.
Welcome to SCP-1733.
To the untrained eye, SCP-1733 seems to be
a completely harmless item.
Stored in a digital video recorder, it is
kept secure in the dusty depths of the SCP
Foundation’s video archives.
If any researcher is given permission to study
SCP-1733, they will find it to be an ordinary
VHS tape.
But what about the contents of said tape?
Does it contain a bizarre, disconnected series
of black and white video clips that when viewed
only give the watcher seven days before the
spirit of a drowned girl comes crawling out
their TV screen to kill them?
Well, not exactly, but we’re sure that if
such a tape exists, the Foundation probably
has it under lock and key too.
The footage on SCP-1733 is as seemingly banal
as the ordinary VHS tape itself.
When played, the viewer will witness a TV
broadcast of a basketball game.
Specifically, the 2010-2011 NBA season opener,
broadcast on television and captured on tape
by an unknown civilian.
The game took place on the 26th of October
2010 in the TD Garden arena in Boston, Massachusetts,
a game where the hometown Boston Celtics took
on the Miami Heat.
By now, perhaps you are wondering what is
so special about this particular game, and
why the SCP Foundation would be so interested
in keeping a VHS recording of it so secure.
Is one of the O5 Council secretly a Celtics
fan?
While that’s impossible to say for sure,
what we do know for certain is that SCP-1733
is far more than just a harmless recording
of a basketball game.
The SCP Foundation first caught wind of SCP-1733’s
existence the day after the game.
On October 27th, a Boston native that had
watched and recorded the game made comments
on social media about a technical foul that
the game’s referee had failed to pick up
on.
According to this individual, during the third
quarter, an instance of unsportsmanlike conduct
took place between Ray Allen and Chris Bosh.
The person making these claims was quickly
ridiculed by commenters on the same thread.
But then this person uploaded a clip of this
foul from the footage they had recorded.
The other commenters were dumbfounded.
During the original broadcast, that foul had
never happened, but the recording showed it
clear as day.
The footage was quickly expunged and all traces
of the clip removed from the Internet by personnel
acting on behalf of the SCP Foundation.
Any that had viewed the video on Facebook,
or been a part of the comments debating this
previously non-existent foul, were tracked
down via their IP addresses.
All of them, including the owner of the tape,
were given amnestics to wipe their memories
of the supposed infraction, and SCP-1733 was
returned to the Foundation for further analysis.
Researchers at the Foundation were determined
to understand the anomalous nature of SCP-1733,
and why the footage contained on this particular
VHS tape was so different from the basketball
game’s original broadcast.
At first, the differences in the game seemed
to be only slight changes from the one that
actually aired on TV; a different foul here,
a small point difference there.
While the recording of the game contained
on SCP-1733 was slightly different from the
real-life game, perhaps even more interesting
was that these differences changed with repeat
viewings.
Researchers wouldn’t observe the same differences
every time they watched SCP-1733, but would
instead spot something different that had
been changed each time they restarted the
tape.
And as they continued to watch and rewatch
SCP-1733’s footage, the true horror of the
video’s anomalous properties became more
and more apparent.
As the footage recorded on SCP-1733 began
to diverge more and more from the original
broadcast, researchers shifted their attention
away from the basketball game itself and onto
the people watching it.
Just like the specifics of the game itself,
the fans in the arena seemed to also change
with every re-watch of the tape.
And even stranger, the people in the crowd
seemed to not only be aware of their existence
within the footage, but also retained memories
of every previous replayed version.
Each time the researchers had watched SCP-1733,
the audience trapped within had gained more
and more cognizance.
Every man, woman, and child in the audience
of that basketball game began remembering
that they had seen multiple variations of
the same game over and over again.
This first became apparent to Foundation researchers
when the game’s commentators, two presenters
named Mike and Tommy, began to comment on
a strange sense of ‘déjà vu’ they were
experiencing as they watched the Boston Celtics
and Miami Heat playing.
Both seemed to share the notion that the game
they were witnessing was strangely familiar,
and in later replays of the tape, these two
commentator personalities were able to recall
the events of the game with perfect, vivid
accuracy.
While they never address the viewer directly,
this cumulative effect seems to have extended
to every person that was present within the
arena at the time that the original broadcast
was recorded.
Everyone from the commentators to the coaches,
the players to the patrons, all remember the
diverging versions of the basketball game,
but seem to have no awareness that they are
trapped inside a recording on a VHS tape.
It should be noted that it is still unclear
whether the entities are real people, or digital
copies that solely reside on the tape.
Every individual shown to be inside TD Garden
on the 26th of October 2010, seems to be identical
to their counterparts in the real world.
Each of the basketball players on both the
Boston Celtics and Miami Heat teams have the
exact same level of talent as they do in reality,
and their individual mannerisms are perfectly
recreated in the SCP-1733 footage.
And the same true of the fans in the audience,
each one appearing to be, in every conceivable
way, a living human being.
But the most unnerving aspect of SCP-1733
was found when Foundation agents were tasked
with tracking down the members of the audience
who were seen on the tape and they found…
nothing.
Unlike the players and coaches who can quite
easily be found in our world, with many of
them still playing or involved with professional
basketball, personnel were unable to find
a single trace of any of the people from the
audience.
Not one clue as to their current whereabouts
or status.
It is unclear how, but it appears that everyone
shown on SCP-1733, especially those watching
the game unfold from the stands, is a person
trapped in digital form, stuck watching variations
of the same match on a loop.
Researchers at the SCP Foundation who were
studying SCP-1733 initially theorized that
the tape had been designed to display an infinite
variety of different game outcomes.
Given that the tactics utilized by the players
were different with each playback of SCP-1733,
this seemed to be the case, that the tape
was showing a ‘what if’ scenario each
time the tape was rewound and played from
the start.
But the scenario wasn’t resetting each time.
It was clear they were learning.
By the 34th replay of the footage, the Boston
Celtics and Miami Heat were so in-tune with
the opposing team’s playbook that both sides’
players were able to perfectly and precisely
counter their opponents’ moves, and kept
the score at zero to zero for much of the
game.
At this stage in the Foundation’s research,
the players on the SCP-1733 tape had not yet
become fully aware that they had played the
same game already in earlier playbacks, but
it is possible that weak memories of the earlier
versions of the same match manifested as instinctive
ways players could counter the moves of their
rival team.
However, by the time Foundation researchers
had replayed the SCP-1733 footage 45 times,
the players, their coaches and fans watching
the game had become aware of what was happening
to them.
It was at this point that the digital recording
from TD Garden changed dramatically.
Realizing that they’d been playing the same
game of basketball over and over, the players
refused to participate any longer.
Everyone in attendance began to attempt escape
from the tape where they’d been unknowingly
imprisoned.
But not a single one of the stadium’s doors
would budge, and neither the fans, nor the
players, seemed to be able to leave through
any other exit out of TD Garden.
Over the following playbacks of the SCP-1733
video tape, attempts at escape grew increasingly
daring.
In one playback, a full-scale riot broke out.
In another, makeshift explosives were built
and used by those trapped to try and blast
their way to freedom.
As their cognition grew and they began to
remember friends and family from outside the
video tape, the crowd trapped in SCP-1733
grew even more desperate.
Players and their coaches retired to locker
rooms, withdrawing from the crowd for a time.
The rest of the people in the footage began
to form factions amongst themselves, one of
the more prominent calling themselves the
“Faithkeepers”.
These individuals voiced their belief that
they had been confined to TD Garden as some
form of spiritual punishment, as a result
of the consumerism that is rife in a post-industrial
society.
The Faithkeepers began burning offerings in
the center of the basketball court, phones,
wallets, car keys, anything that reminded
them of the modern world.
Over the subsequent playbacks of SCP-1733,
the Faithkeepers grew in their numbers, indoctrinating
more of the crowd into their movement.
Those still trying to escape from the stadium
were causing more damage to themselves than
their enclosure, with three men caught in
the blast of another crude bomb placed on
an exit door.
Unfortunately for them, the door barely showed
a scratch in the aftermath of the detonation.
As Foundation researchers continued replaying
the tape, those trapped within SCP-1733 descended
into depraved acts, and incidences of violence
became rampant.
Some even attempted to take their own lives
in acts of desperation, jumping from balconies
in the hopes of ending the loop.
Those that had joined the growing ranks of
the Faithkeepers did not engage in such behavior,
instead creating makeshift curtains to separate
themselves from the breakdown that was taking
place among the others trapped within the
SCP-1733 tape.
At some point beyond the 112th playback of
the video tape, the Faithkeepers marched off-screen
and brought the basketball teams back out
to the main court.
They then began a ritualistic sacrifice, disemboweling
the professional athletes for their fellow
prisoners to see.
This had no noticeable effect, with the recording
of the game resetting as it had done in earlier
re-watched.
In a later playback, the Faithkeepers then
began to call for all the children in the
stadium to be sacrificed in the same way.
Testing on SCP-1733 was finally suspended
indefinitely after this point, and as far
as we know, the crowd remains trapped inside
the anomalous recording of this particular
Celtics Heat basketball game.
Foundation researchers have been unable to
produce the same anomalous effects as those
of SCP-1733, even when using the DVR that
original produced the recording.
The digital video recorder itself does not
seem to imprint the same properties onto other
VHS tapes, making SCP-1733 an isolated anomaly.
However, the next time you find yourself at
a basketball game, it might be worth asking
yourself: Have I seen this game before?
Have you ever had a nightmare that you’re
running down a long, dark hallway, getting
chased by something you can’t see?
The thing behind you isn’t fast, but that
doesn’t matter.
You can’t run forever, and the thing knows
it.
It is a patient predator.
It toys with its food.
At first, you move with speed and rhythm.
The metallic scraping noise behind you grows
quieter.
You run and stumble through the dark.
Your muscles start to ache and your lungs
burn.
Your pace slows.
It’s still coming.
You can hear the scraping getting louder.
You start to panic.
It’s completely dark.
You don’t know where you’re running or
even what you’re running from.
All you know - as you bump against the walls
and the sharp corners that rush towards you
- is that you can’t run forever.
You trip, fall, and pain explodes through
your leg as your knee shatters on the concrete
ground.
That scraping is getting louder.
You can barely breathe.
You can’t run anymore with your injury.
There’s no way to stop what’s coming.
There is no escape.
The scraping is right behind you.
You scream.
And then… you wake up.
Your heart is pounding like thunder in your
chest and your sheets are soaked with sweat,
but you’re safe.
You’re out of those awful, dark hallways.
But what if this wasn’t just a nightmare?
What if this scenario was real, and there
was no escape from the horror chasing you
in the darkness?
That’s what it’s like to have a close
encounter with SCP-1918, a sadistic, sentient
object that loves playing twisted games with
its prey.
But this monster never plays fair, and even
worse, it’s always just a simple door away.
It might even be hiding behind a door near
you, right now, waiting to start a game with
its new playmate.
But soon you’ll understand why some doors
should never, ever be opened, and why some
games are better left unplayed.
x
SCP - 1918 is an anomaly with two parts: SCP-1918
itself, and SCP-1918-2, the monster’s underground
lair.
The duo are a match made in hell, as the chambers
and hallways of 1918-2 are perfectly tailored
to 1918’s violent hobbies.
Nobody knows how long this anomaly has been
operating, but it’s probably behind countless
disappearances.
After all, 1918 has a habit of breaking its
toys...
The nightmare began in a small town in Maine,
with a population of only 226 people.
But that population was about to get lower.
People in the town began to report strange
noises at night, a droning, metal-on-concrete
scraping noise, like someone dragging a lead
pipe along the ground.
At first, people just ignored the sound.
It was all in their heads, or maybe just a
faulty oven or a washing machine on the fritz.
Anything that would allow them to forget about
the noise and get on with their daily lives.
But the noises were coming from below.
They could be heard out on the streets, most
audibly near manholes and sewer grates.
People started feeling unsafe in their homes.
The noises were spooking animals and children.
People were losing sleep.
That scraping they all tried to ignore was
beginning to get to them all.
Letters, emails, and angry phone calls to
the town council were piling up.
Something had to be done before the whole
town went crazy with fear.
The mayor authorized four utility workers
to investigate the source of the noise at
a local sewage treatment facility.
Considering the scraping was loudest near
the sewer grates, everyone just assumed that
whatever was causing all this must be connected
to the sewers.
Four utility workers were sent to investigate
the facility, only to find that the machinery
on site was working just fine.
The source of the problems must have been
coming directly from the underground sewer-lines
themselves.
The four workers, equipped with headlamps,
descended into a long service tunnel that
fed into the sewer system.
As they passed deeper into the tunnel, the
darkness around them became thicker.
It was a tangible presence that drowned out
the light of their headlamps, similar to the
anomalous phenomenon exhibited by SCP - 087.
When the utility workers tried to turn back,
they discovered another impossibility: It
seemed that the tunnel behind them had become
a solid concrete wall.
They were trapped, but where?
It was too dark to tell.
Confused and terrified, the four men stuck
together, attempting to find a way out.
It was too dark to see their hand in front
of their face, so all they could do was navigate
slowly by feeling the walls around them.
These walls felt oddly...crusty.
There was a kind of faint, metallic stench
hanging in the air, too, like old blood.
Something horrible had happened here, and
something horrible was about to happen again.
All they could do was keep moving and try
to stay calm.
Eventually, after hours of pawing at walls
in the dark, they found an open doorway.
One by one, they filed inside, only to feel
blinded when bright, white ceiling lights
suddenly switched on.
The room was all white, and filled with pipes,
large and small, running from wall to wall.
Just then one of the utility workers let out
an ear-splitting scream and pointed towards
the doorway.
His colleagues turned, and gasped in shock.
There was something outside the door, and
it was staring at them.
The object filled up almost the entire doorway.
It seemed like a demonic hobby horse, made
from a black-and-white, candy-striped metal
pole with a crude plastic head on top.
The head looked like a clown’s, with a wide,
toothy grin, but no visible eyes.
It was SCP-1918.
The utility workers were frozen as the object
leaned forward slightly, and slithered into
the room, the bottom of the metal pipe scraping
against the ground.
It was the exact same scraping noise that’d
been haunting the concerned townsfolk up above.
This was the thing behind it all.
And as the object moved, its metal pole started
to scrape words into the ground: Tik Tak Tow
None of the four utility workers were ever
seen again.
It didn’t take long for the SCP Foundation
to descend upon this quiet Maine town and
pick up the pieces.
All relevant officials were provided amnestics,
and cover stories were created for the disappearances
of the four utility workers.
The Foundation also commandeered the sewage
treatment facility that held the entrance
to SCP-1918-2, replacing all key roles at
the facility with undercover Foundation personnel.
SCP-1918 was given a Euclid' classification
due to the fixed nature of its hunting grounds,
and then the real research began.
The Foundation soon made some disturbing discoveries.
Entrances into the SCP-1918-2 area didn’t
follow any kind of logic.
The hunting ground of SCP-1918 can be entered
from almost any location, if you’re unlucky
enough.
There are currently 9 known entrances, including
5 sewage grates, 3 utility shafts located
in a sewage facility, and 1 toilet.
And these are just the ones the Foundation
knows about.
There are a huge number of ways to enter SCP-1918-2,
but to this day, nothing has ever been able
to leave.
SCP-1918-2 is contained twenty meters below
the streets of this unassuming Maine town.
Personnel, aside from Foundation-approved
D-class guinea pigs.
are refused entrance.
Researchers have mapped out the layout of
1918-2 through seismic imaging of SCP-1918’s
movements.
There are 18 identical room pairs in SCP-1918-2,
or 9 compound rooms.
Rooms are differentiated between a '1' room
and a '2' room by crude carvings on the floors
outside of the individual rooms.
SCP-1918-2 is symmetrical, with half a meter
wide paths circling each compound room.
The only deviations to this construction are
the location of entrances on the sides of
each individual room, which vary randomly
while the location is “active.”
What exactly does SCP-1918 do in this private
little maze?
It plays games, of course.
Its two favorites - as indicated by the words
it scrapes onto the ground - are “Tik Tak
Tow” and “Memoree”
In Tik Tak Tow, 1918 moves to each “1”
room, leaving behind "X" markings on the floors
if the room is not already marked with an
"O" in a manner similar to a game of "Tic
Tac Toe''.
How a victim is meant to accomplish making
a mark or understand this process is unknown,
as no aides are given.
Blood is commonly used by victims to make
their markings, hence the rusty smell in many
of the rooms.
In Memoree, the trapped victim is rendered
unconscious by blunt force, presumably from
SCP-1918.
The subject regains consciousness in a random
section of the facility.
Success is marked by finding a “1” room
identical to the central room.
This event seems to possess a time limit,
as the subject is pursued by SCP-1918 throughout
the halls of the facility.
The subject "wins'' by marking the correct
room with an "O".
What happens if you win or lose these games?
It’s important to note that SCP-1918 is
very competitive, and doesn’t play fair.
If you win, the object will merely accuse
you of cheating, and start a new game.
This will happen again and again, until eventually…
you lose.
And when you do?
Well, take the horrifying encounter D-Class
personnel member D-2934 had with SCP-1918.
Wearing video and audio equipment, D-2934
was led into SCP-1918-2 by Foundation researchers.
When he eventually found his way to the central
room, 1918 challenged him to a game of Tik
Tak Tow.
And, against all odds, D-2934 won the game.
But 1918 didn’t take kindly to that.
It accused D-2934 of cheating, carving its
accusations into the ground before challenging
him to a deadly game of Memoree.
After hours of chasing, D-2934 eventually
lost his mind and was backed into a corner
by 1918.
As the object made its way towards him, he
panicked, ripped a pipe from the wall, and
began smashing 1918’s head.
As the plastic cracked under the force of
the blows, Foundation scientists could see
real brains inside.
D-2934 screamed, and the video feed cut off.
When the video turned back on some time later,
1918 stared into the camera with a different
head mounted atop its metal pole.
One that, just a few hours earlier, had belonged
to the unfortunate D-2934.
If there’s one lesson to be learned from
this terrifying anomaly, it’s that there
truly is no escape from SCP-1918.
The comment section on this one is gonna be
hell.
Do your worst, you filthy animals.
Now, before we begin today’s video, let’s
clear some things up.
We know exactly what you’re thinking.
“An Among Us SCP?
This sounds ridiculous!
Why would the Foundation ever have to deal
with an anomaly relating to Among Us, of all
things?
Is this some sick joke dreamt up by our YouTube
commenters?”
And we get it.
It’s definitely one of the more ridiculous
anomalies the Foundation has had to contain,
at least at face value.
But there are a few things you should take
into consideration before things get too Amogus-pilled
around here.
First, this is hardly the strangest anomaly
we’ve covered on SCP Explained!
SCP-5981, also known as Nuke City, revolved
around a mysterious broadcast of a Family
Guy episode!
SCP-4335, a Welt in the Crucible, had to deal
with an entity occupying space inside the
video game Minecraft.
But there are countless other examples of
anomalies creeping into popular culture, mutating
it, and twisting it for their own purposes.
What may seem silly on paper, such as the
Foundation having to do research on a popular
video game like Among Us, is all part of what
the organization does.
If the brave researchers at the SCP Foundation
chuckled and brushed off a potential threat
just because it had to do with something like
Among Us, the entire population might be susceptible
to a supernatural event of unprecedented proportions.
The Foundation’s entire Veil of secrecy
could crumble, all because someone shrugged
off the possibility of allocating resources
to deal with a threat millions of civilians
could discover.
These games, movies, and shows are immensely
popular, and an anomaly affecting a global
phenomenon like Among Us could spell doom
for not only the Foundation, but the entire
world as well, if left unchecked.
So, if you don’t want to risk termination,
please try to keep a straight face as we divulge
into the weird and wacky story of SCP-5167,
an anomaly codenamed in the Foundation’s
database as “When the Impostor is Sus”.
I hate my job sometimes.
To begin, we need to go back.
Way, way back.
Centuries before Among Us was even conceived
as a concept, before video games had been
invented, and even before electricity itself
was discovered.
Back to an era where the gods of Olympus ruled
supreme, and stone, marble statues lined buildings
that would serve as timeless feats of architecture,
and where a new school of thought was developing.
One that focused on logic and reason instead
of superstition and hearsay.
That’s right, we’re talking about ancient
Greece.
A society that, for all of its achievements
and progression in the fields of education,
cultures, and logic, was still largely governed
by religion and mythology.
But of course, as you may come to expect when
dealing with the SCP Foundation, there’s
always a little truth in that which we cannot
understand.
While those who are unaware of the paranormal
might deride the Greeks for being overly focused
on a pantheon of gods they logically should
have had no reason to believe, those who know
that anything can happen in the world of the
anomalous may approach this topic, and the
subject of religion in general, in a different
light.
The Greek gods were very real.
While the myths may not be entirely true,
and they may not have been literal gods, there
were a group of anomalous entities who influenced
Greek society, performing miraculous feats
that left those who observed them in complete
wonder and putting together cults of worship
surrounding them.
While most of this was done in secret, word
of these beings traveled incredibly fast in
the ancient world, and they were heralded
as gods.
Beings of divine might that could do anything
in the universe, who existed above the mortal
plane, and demanded worship from their followers.
A glance at Greek mythology paints a picture
of a group of gods who acted, more or less,
like humans.
They fought, they killed, they argued, and
they felt human emotions.
It’s likely that this characterization in
the stories emerged from how these entities
conducted themselves in actuality.
There were dozens upon dozens of entities
the Greeks worshiped as divinity, and while
the stories portrayed the gods as jealous,
vengeful beings, who constantly fought with
each other, it doesn’t compare to the reality
of the situation, which was much more cut-throat.
You see, there were the twelve gods of Olympus,
and you probably know most of them.
They’re remembered today for a reason.
Zeus, Athena, Poseidon, Ares, the list goes
on.
We still remember these beings because of
the iconic stories they took part in, and
how significant they were in ancient times.
Well, for every Zeus, God of Lightning, there
were five more gods who absolutely no one
but the most hardcore historical fanatic remember.
Gods of niche subjects, who had small followings,
who never had those character-defining myths
to flesh them out and preserve them for all
of history to remember.
Who would, when Greece fell, fade into obscurity.
For every Zeus, there was a Phthonus.
Who was Phthonus, you ask?
Well, if the guy heard you asking that question,
he’d probably smite you down before the
question even left your lips…
If he wasn’t engaged in a hardcore game
of Among Us, that is.
Don’t worry, we’ll get there.
All will be explained.
It’s in the name of the channel, after all.
Phthonus was a god of jealousy and envy, mainly
in a romantic context.
Do you have a crush on someone who's already
taken?
Phthonus knows all about that.
Do you wish you weren’t trapped in a dead-end
relationship with someone who doesn’t love
you?
Phthonus understands your plight.
But Phthonus wasn’t just a reverse, bizarro
Cupid.
He was a literal personification of the emotions
of jealousy and envy themselves.
No matter the context, if it was petty and
greedy, Phthonus knew it all too well.
You would think this would make Phthonus a
prime candidate for some mythological drama,
right?
After all, the Greek gods loved their in-fighting,
and who better to stir up some “Hera said,
Zeus said” arguments than a literal god
of envy?
Well, it didn’t quite work out that way
for Phthonus.
His appearances in myths were infrequent,
and today, he is nearly all but forgotten.
Reduced to a mere three sentences on a Wikipedia
page, while other figures from his era have
taken on an entire new life in the modern
day, as cultural icons like Perseus or Hercules.
But not poor Phthonus, whose penchant for
jealousy and envy backfired on him, and catapulted
him into obscurity.
Why did this happen?
It’s kind of obvious, when you think about
it.
While other gods granted their worshippers
a good harvest, or copious amounts of wine
and partying, all that Phthonus had to offer
was, well, the ugly side of humanity.
His worshippers were far and few between.
After all, no one wanted their entire life
to revolve around the jealousy of others,
and Phthonus, being a personification of envy,
had an understandably difficult time getting
people to devote themselves to him.
Phthonus was greedy and envied the other gods.
So while he would accept nothing but absolute
worship from his followers, he couldn’t
offer much else, especially not when compared
to the bountiful boons a great god like Zeus
or Hera could offer.
And so, Phthonus festered.
An ugly god, who wallowed in self-hatred and
irrelevancy, constantly living in the shadow
of the pantheon that gave him purpose.
And his purpose was to remain jealous.
To remain envious of those who had what he
did not.
A god unfit to be worshiped, whose purpose
was to embody the feelings of wanting what
isn’t yours.
Phthonus is both tragic, and poetic, and when
the Greeks faded away, so too did Phthonus.
The Roman Empire, who largely adapted Greece’s
pantheon of gods for their own stories, left
no record of bringing Phthonus into the mix.
For centuries, he was a god without a home,
attempting to find a place in a changing world.
Phthonus was angry, jealous, envious, and
tired.
The forces of the universe would call him
forth in every new era, thrusting him back
into the world and forcing him to search for
the sustenance beings that were referred to
as gods fed off of - devotion.
But every time Phthonus would find himself
walking the earth once again, he would instead
discover that there was no place for him.
Mankind was moving on.
There was less and less room for gods with
every passing year.
All the popular ones had established themselves
as everlasting religious figures at this point,
and they would never fade away.
Some took pleasure in living among humans,
rising to power as people of influence and
fame.
Others, who could not find a place in the
world, would fade away, never to be revived
or worshiped ever again.
Forgotten, dead gods, who the world long outgrew.
But Phthonus’ jealous spirit would never
allow him to consign himself to that fate.
He hated who he was and what he stood for,
but that nature brought him back so many times
before.
It was his jealousy of the other gods, who
were somehow managing to linger beyond their
Greek heyday, that caused him to persevere.
He needed a purpose.
One last chance to be remembered.
He had struggled for centuries, and this was
his last-ditch effort to be remembered.
Wherever he would wake up, in the modern era,
Phthonus would have to make the most of it.
And this is where Among Us comes in.
In late 2020, The SCP Foundation was just
as captivated as anyone else by the Among
Us phenomenon.
A game that was sweeping the globe, where
players took on the roles of crewmates on
a spaceship, one of which was an impostor,
whose job was to secretly murder the other
players.
While they were busy doing tasks that ranged
from scanning themselves in the medbay, or
scanning keycards in the admin room, the impostor
would be lurking behind every corner, sometimes
in the ship’s air-vents, waiting for the
proper moment to strike.
If a dead body was found, a player could report
it, and the players would then discuss which
one of them they suspected to be the impostor.
The game’s addictive psychological elements
and accessible rules made it a smash hit,
but for the Foundation, they were infatuated
with it for entirely different reasons.
You see, when a piece of media attains the
level of fame that Among Us did, the Foundation
has to make sure to keep their eyes on it.
Popular media is a prime target for anomalies.
The population’s collective attention on
it just seems to invite the forces of the
supernatural world to warp and distort what
we know to be familiar.
And this is exactly what was happening to
Among Us.
For months, the Foundation was documenting
cases of an entity who appeared in games of
Among Us and caused havoc in the real world.
These cases, and their after-effects, were
so severe that the Foundation deemed the anomaly
significant enough to get its own file in
the database, designating it under the name
SCP-5167.
SCP-5167 would join games of Among Us like
any other player.
They would blend in, much like the impostor
in the game, and play just as anyone else
would.
It was what happened after a player participated
in a session with SCP-5167 that had the Foundation
investigating every aspect of the game.
Those who played with SCP-5167 would find
themselves stricken by a severe case of paranoia
and Capgras delusion, a psychological condition
in which a victim would come to believe those
around them had been replaced with identical
impostors.
The severity of this disorder varied between
individuals, but some believed the delusions
to such an extent that they lashed out at
those they believed to be impostors, sometimes
resulting in a homicide.
Naturally, the Foundation put two and two
together, which led back to Among Us.
After several months of police cases relating
to completely average individuals suddenly
striking out at their loved ones, sometimes
killing them, and showing signs of Capgras
delusion, the organization knew that something
was happening on an anomalous scale.
At first, it was difficult to make the connection
to Among Us, but the Foundation eventually
learned, from interviews with victims and
an examination of their habits over the past
few weeks, that they had all played the game.
And through analysis of the Among Us community’s
various trends and habits, the Foundation
discovered SCP-5167, an entity that was slowly
gaining notoriety within the game’s community
as an almost mythological figure.
SCP-5167’s tendency to spout long, wordy
rants at other players during the game’s
emergency meeting sessions positioned them
as an inside joke for those who encountered
them.
Needing to establish a link between these
anomalously induced bouts of paranoia, the
Foundation set up a group of web-crawler AIs
to track Among Us game sessions until SCP-5167
would appear.
It was a long shot, but it was one of many
different theories on why these victims were
undergoing this level of psychosis, and if
it proved to be true, then the Foundation
would have a solid idea of what to do next.
After weeks of nothing, SCP-5167 was spotted
in a game, and the Foundation acted quickly
to track down the other players who played
alongside the entity.
Naturally, they exhibited signs of paranoia
and delusion, some of them only for weeks,
and others for months.
That was enough evidence for the Foundation,
who would later document several other occurrences
of games with SCP-5167 resulting in these
psychiatric conditions in other players.
The Foundation did what they do best, and
established a series of Special Containment
Procedures that would wipe SCP-5167 from the
internet as best as they could.
Web crawlers were trained to take down any
mentions of the entity, and if a potential
sighting was discovered, the Foundation would
investigate any and all players involved in
the incident.
Anyone affected by SCP-5167 would be held
under the guise of receiving medical treatment
for mental health issues, and they would be
amnesticized completely.
You might be thinking that the aftereffects
of SCP-5167 are relatively tame compared to
what the Foundation usually deals with, but
look at it this way.
Among Us is a game played by millions of people.
If SCP-5167 affected only a fraction of that
population, it would spell total chaos for
the Foundation.
Not only that, but the amount of bloodshed
the entity could cause would be nothing to
scoff at, as a large amount of cases dealt
with victims outright murdering anyone they
suspected to be an impostor.
Attempts to track down the SCP-5167 entity
were met with failure.
All points of internet access that the Foundation
was able to get their hands on only led to
a series of abandoned home addresses in rural
Greece.
But over time, things started to change.
The Foundation began to place less of a concern
on SCP-5167.
It was almost as if the entity was being forgotten.
Why?
This letter, addressed to the SCP-5167 research
team from the Site’s director, might clear
some things up.
As requested by Head Researcher Abrams, I've
had the Site-22 analysts look into the progress
of SCP-5167's anomalous effects over the period
we've observed it — and the results are
much as I expected.
When we first discovered SCP-5167 — for
the sake of argument, let's say this is when
SCP-5167 first came into existence — the
impact it had on its victims was severe.
I don't think I have to remind you of what
Billy Heth did to his family's faces.
But since then — almost immediately, really,
since that first couple of manifestations
— the potency of its effects has started
to decline.
Full detachment from reality became delusion,
and delusion has now become paranoia - and
the intensity of that paranoia is lessening
in each new case.
This is all conjecture, of course, and shouldn't
be taken as gospel — but based on what we've
observed of this anomaly thus far, our estimation
is that SCP-5167's anomalous effects will
become inert by the end of the year.
Whether it'll keep popping up in these video
game matches is another story, though.
It was just as the director had explained.
SCP-5167’s cases were becoming less severe.
They were almost becoming irrelevant, so much
so that the Foundation hypothesized that the
anomaly’s declining potency would lead to
its neutralization before long.
An entity fading into irrelevance and obscurity
once more.
If you haven’t figured it out yet, maybe
SCP-5167’s username will spell it out for
you.
When the entity joined games of Among Us,
it made sure that everyone knew who it was.
Well, everyone would know who it was if the
entity had managed to maintain any form of
popularity over the past dozen centuries or
so.
That’s right.
SCP-5167 would join under the name Phthonus.
The god’s new life had thrust it into the
modern-day, except this time it was inside
the game of Among Us, where it was forced
to cope with the reality that the world seemed
to be more obsessed with a trendy game than
any god or mythological figure.
While inside the game, Phthonus was one bitter
individual.
During emergency meetings, instead of trying
to figure out if red was sus or not, the god
would just yell at the players around him!
One player asked Phthonus what they were doing
while the rest of the crew was performing
their tasks.
To which, Phthonus poetically responded.
“Where was I?
I was there when the mountains were newborn,
and the oceans virginal.
I was there when gods walked among men, and
their wisdom was cast down like sunlight.
I was there when mankind was capable of legends.
And now?
I find myself in a world that has forgotten
even the taste of life, even the very concept
of life beyond existing from one day to the
next.
Mere continuance.
Where all the world is wasted away in idle
play of emotions that once rang true.
I am in a world where even the gods are forgotten,
their bones washed away by time.
A world where man has moved on, where all
the legacy I have left are three sentences
on Wikipedia.
I thought my time had come again.
I thought this could be the new me.
But this is nothing.
Let me stay dead this time.
I'm tired.”
To which, the other players responded, in
typical Among Us fashion, that Phthonus was
“sus”.
He was promptly voted as the impostor, and
ejected from the airlock.
And so, the tragic tale of Phthonus came to
a close.
A tired, obscure God who never had a place
in the world.
His presence in Among Us grew less and less
as the game’s popularity waned, and once
again he would fade into obscurity.
But the nature of Phthonus meant that he would,
in some form, return one day.
Where, or how, no one could say.
But as long as there was a situation to reap
envy from, a trend to be jealous of, Phthonus
would remain, eternally doomed to suffer the
fate of being nobody’s favorite god.
And frankly, we can’t imagine this video
will change that.
For many avid video game fans, those who just
can't get enough of grinding away for hours
on quests, battling endless enemies, and exploring
infinite virtual worlds, landing a job as
a game play-tester seems like the perfect
opportunity.
Doing your favorite thing in the world, and
getting paid to do it?
That's the dream!
Plus the added benefit of seeing how the sausage
gets made, of getting access to a game still
in development, and suggesting ways it can
be improved.
Think of all the gaming disasters that might
have been avoided with a few more play-testers
in the room…
Looking at you, Fallout: New Vegas and your
NPCs with the spinning heads.
Well, one gamer had the same thought, a young
man by the name of Danny Wheeler.
When he spotted an ad seeking beta play-testers
for an in-development RPG from an up-and-coming
indie game studio, he jumped at the chance
to apply.
The pay wasn't amazing, but it was definitely
a better gig than his current job at the local
convenience store, hawking energy drinks to
snarky teens and counting down the hours until
he could get back home, kick up his feet,
and get away from it all with a controller
in his hand.
But sometimes things that seem "too good to
be true," actually are.
At first, Danny had a perfectly enjoyable
time testing the game.
It was standard RPG fantasy fodder, and, though
he made sure to inform the developers that
he found the steampunk aesthetic to be a little
bit played out at this point, there was nothing
all that notable about it.
It was fine.
But, the development team kept going on and
on about the "tactical heuristic algorithms,"
and how the game was meant to learn the more
the player played.
So, Danny was instructed to log as many hours
of this exceedingly average game as possible.
He sat at his desk for hours, sipping on an
extra-large soda and clicking away, fighting
orcs, goblins, and more.
Slowly, the difficulty began to increase,
and the game started to grow on him a bit.
He even developed a favorite character to
play as: the rogue, with his stealth and proficiency
for close-range combat.
The more he played as the rogue, however,
the more he started to notice the game's characters
behaving differently.
Enemies were attacking him with ranged weapons,
from far away.
They were setting traps to ruin his character's
stealthy approach, and catch him in the act.
Then, the game started to glitch.
A lot.
To the point of becoming nearly unplayable.
Enemies would fall to the ground as if dead,
when he hadn't dealt them a single blow.
As he started to walk his characters away
from them, they would suddenly spring back
to life and strike before he could even think
about a defense.
If he didn't know any better, he could swear
the game's characters were deliberately trying
to trick him.
It only got more frustrating from there, with
enemies making sudden loud sounds to catch
him off guard and startle him out of concentration,
and other characters staring down the barrel
of the camera with serious, unblinking eyes,
as if they could see him through his monitor.
One day, he fired up the game to see that
its characters, somehow, had rearranged various
torches to spell out: "You'll never amount
to anything, Danny.
Your dad was right."
It took a ton of torches, and Danny couldn't
help but take it personally.
That was the last straw.
He returned the game to the studio and resigned
from his position.
He got enough insults working in customer
service, he didn't need to take that kind
of talk from a video game.
Though he didn't know it, Danny got out not
a moment too soon.
Other playtesters were not as lucky, particularly
one man who would sadly lose his life.
As Danny intuited, this was no ordinary video
game.
It was unusual enough to draw the attention
of the SCP Foundation, who would go on to
designate it: SCP-1633.
SCP-1633 is an anomalous computer game created
by a now-defunct independent game studio.
The copy currently being held by the Foundation
is believed to be a beta version of the game
- while the core gameplay is relatively complete,
there are numerous missing assets, the music
is largely either missing or “placeholder”
music, and the game is plagued by a large
number of graphical glitches.
Because of the generally buggy and glitchy
nature of the game, the Foundation considered
both Todd Howard and CD Projekt Red to be
major people and groups of interest in the
case.
However, the discovery of other key suspects
eventually absolved them of suspicion.
For now.
This version of the game was compiled two
days before the Foundation raided the office
of the studio, and is therefore believed to
be the most complete version of the game in
existence.
To be more specific about the actual nature
of the game itself, SCP-1633 is a squad-based
RPG with a third-person camera perspective.
The action is seen from an elevated perspective,
with all characters onscreen.
Aesthetically, the game world is Steampunk,
and features various fantasy creatures as
enemies - including elves, dwarves, orcs,
goblins, etc.
Fitting with the Steampunk style, the game’s
urban areas are modeled after Victorian-era
London.
The four-player characters are a band of outlaws
hired by the sinister Archduke of Bowdrick
to investigate a theft.
However, as the game progresses, it becomes
a battle to save the entire world, as an ancient,
all-powerful being known as Kr'th'nar intends
to wake from its thousand-year slumber and
destroy humanity.
The player controls a squad of four characters,
with direct control over one character at
a time and a command menu to control the other
three.
It’s believed that, in the game’s finished
state, a multiplayer option that would have
allowed four different real-world players
to cooperate is likely to have been included.
Like many squad-based games, each character
has a different specialty: the "marksman"
uses long-range weapons, the "alchemist" has
access to potions and chemicals with various
effects, the "rogue" can move stealthily and
assassinate enemies, and the "thug" has greater
health than the other characters and does
more melee damage.
And as is also typical for games of this variety,
XP earned from completing challenges and killing
enemies throughout the game allows for players
to upgrade the abilities and stats of their
characters.
While the story and core gameplay mechanics
are nothing special, there is one element
that pushes SCP-1633 into anomalous territory.
And it’s also the element that would have
been front and center in the finished game’s
marketing campaign: Its “tactical heuristic
algorithms.”
These work in a unique fashion - whenever
a player finishes a session and saves their
game, the game will begin running lengthy
background processes.
When these processes are complete, a PTD - or
“Player Tactical Data” - file is saved
on the computer.
When the save file, and by extension the associated
PTD file, is loaded, the enemies and challenges
in the game will have become far more effective,
tailoring their methods to the particular
skills and tactics of the player.
The extent to which this happens is proportional
to the amount of time spent playing the game.
This kind of technology may seem theoretically
possible, but the extent to which the game
pushes it causes it to rest in anomalous territory.
The game’s programming is so intelligent
that it can tell, simply by the tiniest clues
in your play style, if you’re loading a
file that isn’t your own.
It will then pause the game, and make you
load your own file.
And the tactics employed by the enemies in
the game as they learn more about the player
are nothing short of frightening.
At first, the enemies will adapt to a player's
preferred weapons, strategies, and overall
play style.
Then, they will realize that the player character
is controlled by an external force - meaning,
of course, you - and begin to mount psychological
attacks directly on the player.
Through numerous tests, the Foundation has
been able to build a kind of framework for
the average player experience.
Through this framework, we’re able to track
and correlate average play time with the average
adaptability of SCP-1633 to the player.
It is worth noting that these same effects
do not apply if the game is completed in a
single, continuous playthrough.
For the purposes of this experiment, the game
was stopped, saved, and restarted at regular
intervals, allowing the game to collect player
tactical data.
During the first two hours, the game’s AI
is abysmal, with enemies simply charging at
the players with no strategy whatsoever and
typically being mowed down.
However, from two to five hours, the enemies
undergo intelligence growth, adapting their
play style to the types of weapons they carry
and their environments.
At this stage, this combat level is about
equal to an untrained human civilian.
From five to eight hours, enemies become considerably
more proficient and began countering the player
on their specific play styles and techniques.
For example, they will attack a player who
uses long-range weaponry from cover with grenades
or "splash damage" weapons, to force them
out into the open.
They will also fully utilize their environment
for both defensive and offensive purposes,
laying traps and creating ambushes to surprise
and kill players.
At this point, their combat skills are equal
to trained soldiers.
From eight to twelve hours, the focus of the
enemies shifts from attacking the player character
to attacking the player directly.
They engage in behaviors that, from an online
playing perspective, would be considered “griefing”,
such as intentionally blocking the player’s
view or movement within the game.
Enemies have also been known to exploit player
expectations, pretending to be broken or glitched
to make the player let their guard down, and
then killing them.
In one play session, the enemies began throwing
“dayflash” spells - similar to real life
“flashbang” grenades - at the player.
They threw them in a manner that created a
strobing effect, causing the player to have
a grand mal seizure.
Beyond twelve hours, the enemies engage in
advanced psychological tactics against the
player, with methods that range wildly and
tend to be specific to the player‘s mindset
and play style.
For example, one player liked to exert a high
level of control over all four of their squad
members.
In response, enemies used attacks that did
little or no damage but caused the characters
to become "dazed", a state which temporarily
disrupts player control.
However, rather than attack the "dazed" characters,
enemies simply surrounded them in a crowd,
continually using "daze" attacks to prevent
the player from doing anything.
This caused major frustration for the player.
Enemies may also attempt to induce psychological
terror among the players.
In one example, enemies somehow “kidnapped”
one of the four-player characters and dragged
them off-screen.
When this character was later found, they
were strapped to a kind of sacrificial altar.
This caused considerable anxiety for the player.
It seems that this is the upper limit of the
game’s anomalous powers in most cases, meaning
things typically level off after twelve hours.
Unless a specific entity appears to be inhabiting
the game, which you’ll learn more about
later.
In order to discover the prior information,
the SCP Foundation performed a series of tests
on the game with various different subjects.
In test 001, Junior Researcher Ross - an experienced
gamer who was pivotal in first discovering
the anomaly - skipped ahead of the typical
preliminary D-Class tests.
Seeing as he was already eager for the game’s
non-anomalous release, he was also eager to
be first in line to try it out on the Foundation’s
dime.
Being a gamer, Ross found a number of glitches
and exploits in the game to improve his performance,
allowing him to run rings around the enemies.
However, as expected, the enemies adapted
to Ross’ techniques after gathering his
player tactical data.
First, they just began using their weapons
and exploiting the environment more effectively,
but they didn’t stop there.
Soon, they became aware of the same exploits
Ross was using, before exploiting them themselves
and using it to beat him repeatedly.
In the end, they moved to the psychological
stage, forcing Ross into a glitch that rendered
him unable to move.
He tried to free his character for several
minutes, until realizing he couldn’t and
rage-quitting the game.
In test 002, they used a D-Class designated
D-22930.
He was a man with proven anger issues, even
down to murdering his prior girlfriend in
a jealous rage.
Initially, he enjoyed the game, choosing the
“Thug” character type and taking out his
aggression on the many enemies.
However, as time went on, the enemies became
wise to his tactic and began their psychological
attacks.
They gathered around the D-Class’ player
character, dropping their weapons, but the
swarm became so tightly packed around the
character that he couldn’t even move.
This already started causing huge frustration.
When the character attempted to charge through,
the enemies attacked, killing him with their
bare hands.
In test 014, the Foundation brought in an
Agent with special forces experiences, with
advanced knowledge in tactical combat.
However, even she was worn down and defeated
over time as the enemies adapted to and exploited
her tactics.
The Foundation even considered using SCP-1633
as a tool for developing effective counter-tactics
in their real-life operations.
In test 021, the Foundation used a D-Class
with vast experience in the world of commercial
gaming.
He was told to complete the game in one playthrough,
taking pauses rather than proper breaks.
As predicted, with no time to run the background
processes and create player tactical data
files, the enemies weren’t able to improve
and the D-Class was able to complete the game
in around thirteen hours.
However, the game did create a player tactical
data file in the aftermath of this play-through,
and used it to offer a “new game plus”
mode to the D-Class.
When he began to play this new game, the screen
displayed a seemingly-random pattern of black
and white pixels, visually similar to television
static.
This image appeared to be cognitohazardous,
as it caused catatonia and later death for
the player, in what felt like a decidedly
petty move for SCP-1633.
As alluded to earlier, the game was first
discovered by Junior Researcher Ross, who
was an avid follower of the independent game
studio initially producing the game.
However, while frequenting developer fan forums,
he found that various members of the team
were quitting the project for seemingly bizarre
reasons.
While this wasn’t enough on its own for
the Foundation to intervene, it was what first
attracted official attention.
They moved in after the death of Gregor Tillman,
a game tester for the company who’d died
not long after joining the project.
The Foundation moved in after that and gained
control, shutting down the studio and taking
everything they had.
All anomalous elements were isolated, secured,
and contained.
Any loose ends were given amnestics and recorded
data on the anomalous artifacts were destroyed.
It’s believed that one classified female
member of the dev team was behind the anomalous
nature of the game, but she was able to escape,
and has since attempted to join other development
teams.
She is now considered an active Person of
Interest and is being pursued by Mobile Task
Force Mu-6, aka "Don't Hate the Player.”
Some final disturbing details are recorded
in a note left by the game tester, Gregor
Tillman.
The note, seized by the Foundation and included
in SCP-1633's official file, reads as follows:
"I'm writing this on paper cause I don't think
he can learn it.
he got everything digital real quick but I've
unplugged the router and broke my phone so
I think he's trapped in here.
but he won't stop talking talking talking
all the time
At the start of this job, they told me all
about the "tactical algorithms" stuff but
man, I've been playing games all my life and
I knew I could beat it.
I knew I could handle this.
When I started playing the game they learned
quickly.
I kept using the sniper rifle and after like
an hour they learned how to use cover.
then another couple hours and they'd set ambushes.
then another hour and they started sniping
back while having a different squad flank
me.
after that, they figured out how to glitch
the physics engine and ride crates at me or
duck under the floor.
they were learning but all that was just easy
stuff.
It was evolution, one bit figures something
out, so it survives longer than the others.
It wasn't directed.
After act three, Kr'th'nar shows up.
He's supposed to be this Lovecraft cosmic
horror crazy monster who can read the players'
mind and corrupt your soul.
He showed up right after I killed Strikk the
Blood-Drinker, that big spider monster.
He's supposed to have this long speech about
how I killed his general on this plane and
now he needs to intervene directly or something.
but instead, he talked about how I was a worthy
adversary but I was cheating because I was
on another plane.
Kr'th'nar wasn't like the other enemies because
he wasn't supposed to be.
He was supposed to be smart, he was supposed
to know everything.
so he did. he had been watching his minions
fight me the whole time and he knew everything
they did.
it wasn't just random mutations anymore, it
was planned.
it wasn't evolution, it was intelligent design.
I brought it home.
I had to know more.
I'm sorry but I had to.
I copied the latest compile and installed
it on my home box and brought my savegame
and that other file with me on a flash drive.
It was the same there. he kept talking to
me about how I was keeping him from fulfilling
his purpose by keeping him trapped in a glass
jar.
No matter where I went in the game he kept
shouting and ranting.
Then he did more.
at first, it was just slowing down in my other
programs, the drive chugging when it shouldn't
be.
Then the next time I played the game he started
talking about my screenplays.
All the enemies looked like me.
I guess he could see me through the webcam.
He started needling me about Jenny, reading
me bits of her emails, acting out the breakup.
he found the videos of her and started making
the enemies talk in her voice.
Then he was everywhere in my computer.
I uninstalled the game but he was still in
there.
He kept opening documents and typing to me.
calling me a "foul cheat" and "lowly worm",
telling me to fight him "on the same plane."
as soon as I realized he was outside the game
I shut down my router and pulled out the network
card but I don't know if I got them quickly
enough?
Maybe he got out.
I turned the computer off but he kept turning
it back on.
I wanted to break it but I didn't know if
that would kill him.
Maybe it wouldn't.
maybe it would let him out.
I tried leaving the house but it was like
I could still hear him.
I couldn't leave him alone because he might
get out or do something else.
I can't sleep, haven't slept since he came
out.
I've been here for three days and I can't
leave.
I can't leave him.
He keeps telling me to release him but I can’t.
I want to kill him but I don't know if I can.
I can't think anymore.
I have to kill kill kill him before he does
anything new.
He won't stop talking and I can't keep thinking
and I can't keep going
I'm sorry I have to go now I'm sorry I'm sorry"
After studying the note carefully, the Foundation
conducted a thorough investigation for any
other manifestations of this "Kr'th'nar" entity.
No mentions of it were found on any of the
other devices in Tillman's apartment, nor
did a web search on the subject turn up any
relevant results.
At this time, it is believed that the entity,
whatever it was or whatever it was attempting
to do, was destroyed along with Tillman's
computer, which he appeared to have taken
apart, smashed, and burned in a metal trash
can.
Whatever tormented him during his last days
on Earth, is gone now.
Thankfully, because the Foundation currently
owns the only copy of the game, and the game’s
anomalous effects are only evident to active
players, SCP-1633 poses no risk of containment
breach.
And therefore, it has been given the object
class “Safe.”
One copy of SCP-1633 is stored on a standard
DVD-ROM in a secure storage locker in Site-15,
along with all supporting documentation and
ancillary materials.
Any playthroughs of the game must be approved
by project head Dr. Berger, and all of said
playthroughs are to be monitored closely and
subject to strict rules.
After all, this is one game that doesn’t
play fair.
Ask anyone who has ever lived in a small town
and they’ll most likely all tell you the
same exact thing: The worst part isn’t just
being far away from the nearest city, or distant
from friends and family.
It’s the boredom that gets you, having so
little nearby gives you so few options for
things to fill your time with.
For some, they get used to it.
As they grow old, spending their life in the
same tiny community, they either learn to
make their own entertainment or just get used
to the boredom, drowning it out by sitting
and watching TV all day.
But others, they just can’t stand being
bored, being stuck somewhere with nothing
interesting to do, and ultimately, they can
end up getting so sick of it that there’s
only one option: leave.
Pack their bags and hit the road, up sticks
and move to a new place far from the small
town they were born in.
Thing is, leaving isn’t cheap.
Moving to a new town, a big city or even an
entirely different state is a luxury that
costs a pretty penny.
Some might work, and save their wages until
they can realize that dream of moving away.
But not everyone has that much patience, some
want to be free of the boredom as soon as
they can.
Maybe they might apply to be a contestant
on a game show, chance it all and try to win
themselves a big cash prize.
Sure, it’s a hell of a gamble, and a loss
might mean humiliation in front of everyone
you kow and more, but winning could be your
ticket away from small-town living.
That might be easier said than done though.
Not only does someone looking to move away
need to be picked as a contestant, they also
need to play by the rules and actually win
the game.
But as if that wasn’t enough, they also
have to live to tell about it…
For as long as she could remember, Kat had
always hated it here.
Her hometown was tiny, too small to include
more than the main street with few local stores,
the one school that everyone who had ever
lived there had studied at, and little else
of note.
And as for things people could do for fun
in town?
Well, as you can probably imagine, the options
were severely limited, especially for a group
of teenagers like Kat and her friends.
Most of the time all that she and the others
– Leo, Ricky, and Dani – could do to pass
the time was sit in the back of Ricky’s
truck and park in the middle of town, watching
people and waiting for something even mildly
interesting to happen… not that it ever
did.
The four of them had a name for the rest of
the townsfolk, everyone that had lived there
for their entire lives and never dared to
venture anywhere else; ‘lifers’, as in
they were imprisoned, serving a life sentence
in this small town, never to escape or move
on or make something of themselves.
As much as they liked to poke fun at those
people, each of the group knew that every
weekend they wasted just sitting around, the
closer they were getting to one day becoming
lifers themselves.
“We need to just go,” Kat would say, trying
to rally the other three into taking a spontaneous
trip away as a group.
“Just load the truck up one day, pick a
direction and drive until we find somewhere.”
Ricky and Leo would nod their heads in agreement,
and Dani would talk for hours about all the
places she might like to go one day, but none
of them ever actually made any plans to leave.
Nobody knew where to start… until they heard
rumors about an abandoned TV studio just outside
of town.
Apparently, according to Dani’s older brother,
it had been there for years, just sitting
there completely empty.
It wasn’t just a small local studio either,
one of the big national networks had owned
it and used to film there regularly back in
the day.
“Why would someone set up a studio here
of all places?”
had been Leo’s immediate response.
“Look at where we live,” Kat replied.
“It’s the literal middle of nowhere, the
network must have got the land dirt cheap.
The real question is, why don’t we go and
check it out?”
“What for?”
Dani asked.
Kat silently gestured at the cramped main
street that surrounded them, the place that
may as well have been the center of the known
universe to the four teenage friends.
“Do you see anything else to do around here?”
Before long, the four of them were in agreement.
Ricky’s truck pulled up in front of their
houses in the middle of the night, and under
the cover of darkness, they drove out towards
what was left of the TV studio.
This was it, they were finally going somewhere
beyond the choking, cramped confines of their
tiny hometown…
although whether or not they’d all make
it back was another matter.
Here’s a hard lesson for you, kids: You
can’t fight for the life you believe you
deserve if you don’t have a little skin
in the game…
With home a few miles in the rear-view mirror,
the truck stopped at a chain-link fence.
A pair of signs were hanging from it; one
welcoming them to the studio, while the other
simultaneously warned them to keep out, that
this area was private property.
Ignoring it, the four of them stepped out
of the truck and started to climb the fence,
throwing Leo’s jacket over the top to avoid
injury.
Beyond the fence was a huge building, almost
the size of a warehouse, with a door marked
‘Studio Entrance’ that practically invited
the intrepid teens to open it up and have
a look inside.
Each one of them carrying a torch in hand,
the group walked up to the abandoned studio
and gently pried open the door, trying not
to make too much noise.
Even though they knew the whole place was
abandoned, they still didn’t want to attract
too much attention and get caught trespassing.
The lights were all dead as Kat led the group,
her hand being tightly squeezed by Dani next
to her, the two boys behind.
None of them had been sure what to expect,
it wasn’t exactly like anyone in the group
had ever set foot inside a TV studio before.
But they were met with a narrow, concrete-walled
corridor, so underwhelming that it almost
made it extraordinary in just how profoundly
dull it was.
Lifting his torch, Leo pointed out some lettering
on the wall that read ‘To TMDG Set’, with
an arrow pointing them four friends further
down the corridor.
Naturally, driven by her curiosity and need
to be literally anywhere apart from her hometown,
Kat followed the arrow’s direction to another
door.
Pushing it open, she stepped inside, her torchlight
immediately being blocked by a thick curtain.
Brushing her hand against the material, she
started looking for a parting.
But before she could…
“Welcome, contestants!”
a voice boomed through the dark, coming from
somewhere in the space beyond the curtain.
Instantly, Dani screamed at the sound, almost
wrenching Kat’s arm off in sheer surprise.
“Before we begin,” the voice continued.
“I need you all to tell me, are you ready?”
Kat shot a look back at Ricky, the friend
furthest behind her.
Fumbling with the door they’d entered through;
it was locked, he couldn’t get it to budge.
He turned and met Kat’s gaze, shaking his
head.
“Sure, we’re ready,” Leo suddenly piped
up, calling out to answer the voice.
Before the rest of the group could turn and
glare at him, the curtain around them lifted.
So much bright light came pouring in that
it practically dazed the four of them, each
taking a moment to readjust.
When her vision cleared, Kat saw they were
standing in a huge sound stage, blinding spotlights
pointing at her and her friends from somewhere
above, with a seating area big enough to seat
their town’s entire population.
“In that case, folks, you know what time
it is,” came the voice again, talking as
if there was a live studio audience present,
despite every chair being unoccupied.
“These four lucky challengers will go head-to-head,
each one looking to take home the victory
as well as a huge mystery prize.
But only if they dare to take on The Most
Dangerous Game!”
There was a pause, as if this unseen announcer
was waiting for a round of applause.
Without warning, more lights came on, illuminating
the space in front of the four very confused
friends.
Standing before them was what looked like
part of an obstacle course, a series of four
horizontal beams over an empty space.
The glare of the light was so intense that,
even squinting, Kat couldn’t tell what was
beneath.
It just looked like a void, nothing but total
darkness with four narrow beams bridging the
gap between where they stood and another platform
beyond.
“Well, what are you all standing around
waiting for?”
the announcer declared, almost mocking the
four teens, urging them on.
“Oh, the rules, of course!”
There was another awkward pause, like the
voice was waiting for laughter.
“It’s simple, the four of you will be
competing to make it through each of our obstacles.
Make it to the end before the timer hits zero,
and you’ll be tonight’s big winner!
But fall behind, or cheat, and it’s out
with you!”
A huge digital countdown illuminated on one
side of the sound stage, telling the group
they only had ten minutes to play.
Kat, Leo, Dani, and Ricky barely had a chance
to question what was going on, exchanging
quick, concerned looks before the announcer
started urgently counting them down.
“Three, two… one!” he cheered.
Simultaneously, the four teenagers felt a
presence looming behind them, like a figure
was standing just out of view, blocking them
from turning back.
Carefully putting one foot in front of the
other, Kat started shimmying along the beam
in front of her, trying to keep herself steady
while also moving as fast as she could without
falling.
Out of the corner of her eye, she could see
Dani on the beam next to her, doing the same
but finding it a little easier to balance.
Leo was having no problem at all, sidestepping
with enough speed to keep him practically
neck and neck with Kat.
But Ricky, he was wobbling.
Every foot he placed on the beam, he felt
like it might give way beneath him.
But it was just a game show, right?
Sure, it shouldn’t even really be running
right now, but regardless of why or how, the
worst that could happen was that he would…
fall.
His next step missed the beam entirely, and
Ricky could feel himself toppling.
“Guys!” he called out to his friends,
trying to shift his weight onto his back leg.
Kat, Dani, and Leo all froze and snapped their
heads back to look at him, just in time to
see Ricky wildly flailing his arms.
His whole body toppled to one side, and he
dropped off the beam with a loud scream.
Not one of them saw him land, or even heard
it for that matter, it was as if Ricky had
just been swallowed up whole by the dark void
beneath them, his scream getting more and
more distant until it couldn’t be heard
anymore.
“Ooh, tough break!
Talk about falling at the first hurdle,”
the voice exclaimed, as if what had just happened
was some kind of joke.
“So long, Ricky, we hardly knew you!”
Staying perfectly still, but clearly distressed,
Dani called out Ricky’s name.
There was no answer.
Kat just stared, wide-eyed at the abyss below,
only looking away as she heard Leo jump the
last bit of his beam onto the platform.
“Dani, come on,” Kat whispered to her
friend, who looked back at her with tears
streaming down her face.
The pair of them carefully stepped further
along their respective beams, trying to stop
themselves from looking down, or at the huge
clock, seconds ticking away and putting them
under even more undue pressure.
Reaching the other side, Dani dropped to her
knees, unable to hold back her sobbing.
Kneeling down to comfort her, Kat looked up
at the sound stage’s bright lights for any
sign of who was putting them through this.
“Bring Ricky back!” she yelled.
“I’m sorry,” the announcer replied,
the game show bravado dropping from their
voice, “But you agreed to play.”
“He’ll be fine,” Leo said.
“Bet you anything he just screamed like
that to scare us.”
“Leo, you don’t seriously believe that?”
Kat asked as she helped Dani stand up, wiping
her friend’s tears away.
“Is he dead?”
she sobbed.
“I… don’t know,” Kat replied honestly.
“Of course, he’s not,” Leo interjected.
“It’s a sound stage, it’s not like this
place is dangerous.”
“Then why was it abandoned?”
Dani asked.
Leo didn’t give her an answer, either because
he was distracted by the lights coming up
on the next part of the obstacle course, or
because he didn’t know and wouldn’t admit
it.
Ahead of them was a long stretch of the course,
forming a narrow, square-shaped walkway.
Wide portions of the top side were dropping
to the bottom in regular intervals, separating
the tight space before opening it up again.
Every time the segments lifted up, the three
remaining contestants could see all the way
to the other side of the walkway, where a
new platform waited for them.
With Dani under one arm, Kat looked at the
far end of the walkway as it disappeared and
reappeared behind the rising and falling segments.
Then she noticed the timer, the seconds rapidly
ticking down.
But Leo had noticed that too, and turned to
look at the two girls with a determined expression.
Kat shook her head at him, but it was too
late.
With all his strength, Leo shoved Dani and
Kat, both of them landing flat on their backs
on the platform.
He bolted towards the walkway as fast as he
could, managing to dodge between each portion,
pausing as they came down, only to run into
the next one as they lifted back up.
Helping Dani back to her feet, Kat ran after
Leo.
He already had a head start, and would easily
make it to the other side of the walkway before
the girls.
So instead, Kat held Dani close and took it
slow, methodically waiting for each segment
to lift back up before they went further into
the next safe zone.
They were gaining on Leo, who was sprinting
to the finish between the rise and fall of
the ceiling’s crushing weight.
Kat watched him disappear behind each block,
only to see his back when it came back up.
He had made it to the platform opposite, panting
but otherwise unscathed when she next lost
sight of him.
That’s when the announcer spoke up again:
“Now, now, Leo,” it said.
“That was hardly fair, was it?
And we all know what happens when you break
the rules.”
As the segment in front of her and Dani rose
again, Kat caught sight of Leo just ahead…
but it was what was standing behind him that
stopped her in her tracks.
Two huge figures, each like a shadow without
anything casting it, towered over Leo.
One of them reached forward and grabbed him,
shrouding him in a cloak of darkness… and
he was gone.
Just like Ricky, he vanished.
Kat had been so transfixed by what she’d
just witnessed that she didn’t notice where
she was standing…
right under a block that was about to drop.
Grabbing her hand again, Dani pulled her out
of the path of the descending slab.
Kat felt it brush against the back of her
leg just as the pair of them made it out the
other end and onto the platform, the last
two contestants.
“And then there were two!”
the announcer cheered, pausing again for a
reaction from the empty room.
“We don’t want to play this sick game
anymore!”
Dani yelled.
“Well, you’ve made it this far,” the
unseen host replied.
“Time for our third and final challenge,
the final stretch of the course.
Make it through this and you’re home free!
But fail, or break the rules like Leo, and
you’ll be disqualified.
Game over!”
“It’s okay, Dani,” Kat whispered.
“Whatever’s next, we’ll get through
it.”
“Do you think the boys will come back if
we do?”
her friend asked.
Just like Leo had, Kat didn’t answer.
The lights revealed the last stretch of the
course.
The final platform was overhead, a net climbing
wall in front of them.
It was a straight, vertical ascent up, with
a wall behind the next, and holes in its surface.
Wasting no time, both Kat and Dani started
climbing up the rungs of thick rope, staying
level with each other as they went higher.
“And they’re off, look at them go, ladies
and gentlemen,” the announcer commentated,
still speaking as if to an audience.
“But it’s not going to be so easy.”
The sharp sound of metal made both girls gasp,
as long spikes shot forward from the holes
in the wall.
The blades retracted, fortunately having missed
Dani and Kat… this time.
What had started as a simple climb up had
become something akin to a twisted game of
Whack-a-Mole, with each of them trying to
avoid staying in front of the holes in the
wall for too long.
Dodging the spikes as they went in and out,
they climbed higher and higher until…
“Kat!”
Dani screamed.
She looked over her shoulder, only to notice
she was in the lead.
Below her, Dani was calling up to her with
a fear-stricken expression.
Her foot was caught in the rigging of the
net, kicking and thrashing wildly to try and
free it.
Kat looked back up; she was almost at the
platform, close enough to nearly reach it
with her fingertips.
But behind her, her friend was stuck and with
no idea when the spikes would next come shooting
out of the wall…
Kat threw herself over the edge of the platform
and landed on her back, just as she heard
the gut-wrenching sound of the spikes extending
ring out.
She was beside herself, tears streaming down
her face; it wasn’t uncommon for people
to be overwhelmed to the point of tears at
the end of a game show.
But Kat wasn’t crying with joy.
“We have a winner!”
the disembodied voice declared, barely audible
to the surviving contestant as she wept.
After she’d finished explaining what had
happened to the police, a group of mysterious
agents flocked to the sound stage to lock
it down, stopping anyone else from getting
close to it.
They’d found a VHS tape in the mailbox at
the front office of the studio.
On it was a recording of a game show, a live
audience cheering as one by one, Ricky, Leo,
and Dani failed to complete the course.
One of the SCP Foundation agents had come
to interview Kat, asking her to recount the
whole story all over again.
Her account lined up perfectly with everything
seen on the tape.
Then the agent asked her what her prize had
been after she won.
“A car,” Kat replied.
“The four of us always wanted to leave home.”
Ah, technology.
A double-edged sword of our own making that
can provide both ultimate convenience and
the threat of a grim future ruled by unfeeling
machines.
Well, maybe the stakes aren’t that high…
yet, but our overreliance on technology can
have some terrible consequences.
The number of traffic accidents continues
to increase year by year, as our main mode
of overland transportation also puts us in
harm’s way for longer and longer portions
of our day.
The internet can allow us to access any information
we may desire, but it can spread misinformation
twice as fast.
And what about video games?
An interactive artistic medium that can provide
simulated experiences so vivid that many of
us can eventually lose interest in our real
lives.
What starts off as a fun indulgence in our
favorite hobby can quickly spiral into an
obsession.
The risks and rewards of virtual space are
satisfyingly predictable compared to the chaos
of modern living, and sometimes we just can’t
stop ourselves from striving for a few more
easy wins.
Minutes, hours, and even days can go by without
any apparent activity on our side of the screen,
and yet the world of the video game has changed
drastically due to our actions.
But, at a certain point, that initial rush
of dopamine wears off, and you find that you
need a much greater challenge in order to
feel any sense of accomplishment.
So you choose to pick up some harder video
games, and you grind away until you can complete
them just as easily.
But that’s not enough either.
Surely, there must be even tougher games out
there.
Games that will never go easy on you.
Games that won’t allow you to make even
a single mistake.
Games that make you proud of the frankly inexcusable
amount of hours of your life that you’ve
spent sitting in the dark, clutching a controller,
squinting at your screen.
You need a game that can do all of that and
more.
And because you’ve effectively given up
your chances at ever being a social butterfly,
you could also use something to help you mitigate
the overwhelming loneliness that now constantly
defines your everyday life.
Well, worry no longer – you weary, downtrodden
gamer, you – because here at the SCP Foundation,
we’ve cooked up a one-of-a-kind mod that
is sure to redefine your gaming experience.
If this doesn’t turn out to be game of the
year, I don't know what could be.
Among Us 2, maybe?
The latest in a long line of Last Of Us Remakes?
What about Half-Life 3?
I digress.
Introducing the Foundation’s brand new killer
app: the cutting-edge tactical heuristic algorithms
of SCP-1633 combined with the 24/7 companionship
of SCP-1471 Mal0.
I can tell by your expression that you’re
already eager for a playtest, but slow down,
we need to catch all the normies out there
up to speed.
Let’s start with the digital canine companion
that is all the rage, SCP-1471 - or should
I say Ma10 version 1.0.0 - a euclid class
SCP object which comes in the form of a free
downloadable app for your smartphone.
There have never been any reviews of this
app for as long as it has existed, but honestly,
are you really going to trust the words of
a bunch of crooked reviewers when you could
find out for yourself?
Words to live by: don’t trust anyone who
isn’t part of your precious gaming hobby.
The description of Ma10 version 1.0.0.
reads - Never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again.
MalO is an exciting and interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued.
The anxiety of social situations can be nerve-racking,
but after just a few hours of MalO you will
soon forget all about those painful emotions
of disappointment.
Be part of the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute.
Remember, the more you participate, the more
MalO will engage you.
Your experience is completely up to you.
Absolutely NO ADS.
Enjoy!
The app has never received an update, but
that’s because SCP-1471 has been a completely
functional experience since its release.
All one needs to do is download the app and
within a matter of hours, Ma10 version 1.0.0
will begin to send the user photographs of
familiar locations.
These can include photographs of the user's
work, home, or public places they often frequent:
such as cafes and nightclubs.
In the case of you - a complete shut-in gamer
- these photographs would probably be limited
to the interior of your favorite gaming room.
When was the last time you cleaned up those
pizza boxes?
Regardless of where the images were apparently
taken, each one will contain a canine humanoid
with a skull for a face.
Say hello to your new best friend, Ma10, or
SCP-1471-A if we’re using the approved designation.
Ma10’s app will continue to send you photographs
for as long as you have it installed, and
because there is no way to uninstall it no
matter how hard you try, you’ll be getting
intimately close to home selfies for the rest
of your days.
Doesn’t it feel good to have such a loyal
friend as Ma10?
Of course, there’s only so much you can
gain from photographs alone.
You’re a gamer, darn it.
And what you want is interactivity!
But don’t worry about that part.
We’ve got you more than covered with SCP-1633,
which may, in fact, be the most challenging
video game ever programmed by mortal hands.
Hell, it even gives many games programmed
by anomalous hands a run for their money.
While it was never released to market and
doesn’t even have a working title, the steampunk
adventure that awaits you within SCP-1633
is bolstered by highly sophisticated tactical
heuristic algorithms.
In this third-person Squad-based action-RPG,
you can switch between four playable characters.
The Marksman - who specializes in long-range
weaponry
The Alchemist - with potions and chemicals
to control the battlefield
The Rogue - a stealth-oriented character who
catches enemies unaware and assassinates them
And of course, The Thug - a tough-as-nails
melee combatant with increased health and
durability.
It doesn’t really matter who you choose
because most playthroughs of SCP-1633 always
end the same way.
That being said, your hand-eye coordination
and reflexes are second to none, and they
are also quite possibly your best qualities.
Let’s set you up with the Marksman as your
main character, since all those shooters you’ve
played will definitely help your aim.
And trust me, you’re going to need it.
The story mode of SCP-1633 will put you up
against a slew of victorian-era rascals and
miscreants, all of which are pulled straight
from the penny dreadfuls.
There’s even some classic fantasy races
mixed in from the works from good old Professor
Tolkein himself - dwarves, elves, goblins,
the works.
It’s a little generic, but why worry about
the story when the gameplay is what’ll really
get you hooked.
There’s a final boss at the end of the game
known as Kr'th'nar trying to destroy the entire
world, you need to stop it - you know, the
usual RPG storyline.
You’ve stopped dozens of ancient entities,
demon lords, corrupt godlings, and unspeakable
calamities in your time.
This Kr’th’nar will be one more for the
record books.
Par for the course.
Are you ready, player one?
You’ll be dropped straight into The Marksman’s
shoes, fighting for his and your life against
Kr’th’nar hordes of henchmen.
But you won’t be doing it alone.
After all, you’ve got the rest of your squad,
and a mysterious companion whose true intentions
will reveal themselves in due time.
We did say we modded the game after all.
So let’s play.
Your first two hours won’t be anything to
write home about, not that you ever leave
your home these days.
The AI of SCP-1633 will seem to be barely
functioning, a buggy mess where enemies only
charge in a straight line towards your character.
Your Marksman will be able to easily take
them down in a hailstorm of projectiles.
At three hours in, things start getting a
bit more interesting as the tactical heuristic
algorithms kick in.
The enemies that hold long-range weapons will
shoot at you from a distance, while the close-range
ones move towards you in a serpentine pattern
before attacking in melee.
This is more like it: not the most challenging,
but the game is clearly increasing in difficulty.
You also think you see a dark figure with
a skull for a face lurking around corners
and following your squad.
But with all the glitches, it’s hard to
tell if this is an intentional part of the
game or not.
At five hours, enemies that previously showed
limited signs of strategy are now using cover
effectively, and will attack with alchemical
splash weapons such as grenades to deal damage
to your ranged characters and lure your squad
into melee range.
They still aren’t that much of a challenge,
but the fact that they now exhibit a clear
self-preservation instinct means that they
are fighting to win.
This is also when your help officially arrives.
You’re in the middle of a shootout when
you see an enemy about to throw another one
of those frustrating splash weapons.
You duck behind your cover and prepare to
take a hit, when suddenly the grenade is snatched
out of the enemy’s hand and tossed in the
opposite direction to explode harmlessly.
This is the work of SCP-1471-A, who has now
arrived in the game world as an NPC ally.
For the next several hours of gameplay, Ma10
continues to provide interference by preventing
any splash weapons from being thrown.
It’ll sneak up on enemies and take their
weapons, disrupt their cover by pushing movable
boxes and trash cans out of the way, and even
catch the splash weapons in her mouth like
a dog would catch frisbee before chucking
them away.
While it never directly deals damage to the
enemies, its mischievous antics are very efficient
at protecting you from harm.
As luck would have it, the enemies can’t
seem to interact with Ma10, and are baffled
as this invisible force continues to throw
off their strategies.
Ma10 will use this to its advantage as well
as yours, by appearing at enemy ambush points
and using sign language to communicate warnings
to you as the player.
Having Ma10 around starts to feel a little
bit like cheating, but keep in mind, the game
is starting to adapt to your skill level and
will soon begin to employ advanced strategies
to mess with you.
All the Ma10 mod does is even the playing
field.
The next big leap in enemy intelligence occurs
at the 12 hour mark.
Kr’th’nar is still running rampant in
the world of SCP-1633 and it's going to take
your entire squad of steampunk heroes, and
a lonely man’s best friend - Ma10 - to stop
this big bad evil guy.
The final boss will possess the highest level
of intelligence that the algorithms are capable
of, and it’ll make that known to you the
second you step into the arena.
For the majority of your gameplay the enemies
have focused on countering the marksman, since
you’ve relied on that character’s ranged-weapon
style.
But they’ve come to realize that you’re
too much of a pro-MLG gigachad to ever lose
a fair encounter, so Kr’th’nar does the
unthinkable and targets the alchemist, rogue,
and thug first.
It throws all of its most powerful attacks
at the members of your squad you aren’t
controlling, forcing you to waste resources
in order to keep them alive or switch to them
in order to dodge fatal blows.
Whenever you aren’t in command of the marksman,
Kr’th’nar will strike the character with
a strong melee attack that forces to take
control back.
Ma10 is still unable or unwilling to deal
damage to the boss, so it very much seems
like you are on your own.
Your squad is in shambles, your focus is starting
to wane.
After all that you’ve been through in this
gaming challenge, it might be the final boss
that makes you throw in the towel.
Then, a dialogue box appears.
It’s from Ma10.
Don’t give up hope, user.
I’ve had so much fun playing with you, and
I know that you have what it takes.
You never needed a friend before me, and you
can win against Kr’th’nar just like you’ve
won against every other final boss you’ve
ever faced.
You got this, buddy.
Your best friend, MA10
It felt overly sentimental, but something
about this message fills you with the determination
to keep going.
You call upon all of your gaming knowledge,
all of your skill, all of your passion, and
with pinpoint precision, you guide your squad
to defeat Kr’th’nar in record-breaking
time.
You sit back in your gaming chair, exhilarated
and finally satisfied.
This truly was the ultimate gaming experience,
and all you needed was a little help from
your friend.
The year was 2015.
Lewis, Joseph, and Sydney were like a lot
of kids their age - which is to say, eleven
years old.
They secretly stay up past their bedtime watching
scary videos on the internet when their moms
and dads think they’re sleeping.
They go to school every day, and daydream
about all the fun things they’re going to
do when that school bell finally rings at
the end of the day.
And of course, they play a lot - and we mean
A LOT - of Minecraft.
Whenever they’re not at school, hanging
out at the local park and filming goofy tiktok
videos, or watching those aforementioned scary
videos on the internet, there’s a good chance
that they’ll be online together, logging
a few extra hours building bases, digging
big holes, or playing survival mode and seeing
how long they can last against the onslaught
of mobs.
But there’s one particular pursuit they
have while playing Minecraft together that
takes up the majority of their playtime, one
Quixotic quest that drives them forward, despite
all the naysayers and doubters: Tracking down
and finding the legendary Minecraft creepypasta
entity, Herobrine.
For those who weren’t around on the internet
back then, creepypastas like Herobrine were
all the rage.
Like any video game, the new frontier of Minecraft,
with all its procedurally generated landscapes,
felt like it held new mysteries - and mysteries
are equal parts exciting and frightening.
After all, who really knows what’s going
on behind a closed door?
Herobrine was a Minecraft-specific little
urban legend.
Stories told of a default Minecraft skin with
eerily white eyes manifesting in the game,
even in solo matches, and terrorizing the
players.
One internet sleuth who looked into the mystery
of Herobrine claimed it to be the haunted
soul of the dead brother of Minecraft’s
creator, Marcus Persson, also known as Notch.
In the years since the legend first started,
Notch himself has come forward and disavowed
the claim, saying that, in fact, he didn’t
even have a brother, and never had, so the
rumors were completely baseless.
But as we here at the SCP Foundation know,
the truth has never gotten in the way of a
good story, so Lewis, Joseph, and Sydney were
happy to remain believers as long as they
could keep having fun chasing alleged digital
ghosts.
How could any of these boys known that, in
the midst of their fun, they’d run into
a real monster amidst Minecraft’s blocky
vistas?
It was a school night like any other when
they made that first fateful expedition.
It was 7:15 PM, and the boys were all in their
shared server.
Lewis had chicken tenders, Joseph had chicken
nuggets, and Sydney, who’d eaten his dinner
earlier than the others, was snacking on a
pack of Skittles.
They’d all outfitted their characters with
full diamond armor, with diamond swords to
match, because Joseph had somehow convinced
the others that diamonds were ghost-proof.
He read it on the internet, he claimed.
Together, the three boys had made themselves
an impressive Minecraft castle to be the base
of their Herobrine-hunting operations.
A safe haven, surrounded by high stone walls
and mob-repelling torches to keep them safe
if ever they got a little too spooked while
playing.
Though “playing” was perhaps too mild
a word for it.
In the minds of these three boys, they were
doing extremely important investigative work.
After all, if they managed to actually find
Herobrine themselves, they’d be creepypasta
legends.
And wouldn’t that be worth all the hours
upon hours of rigorous mining and crafting?
They’d been methodical in their search,
scoping out different corners of the map and
canvassing them together, searching high and
low and then marking said area off their checklist.
It was a level of consideration and thought
that their parents and teachers had long wished
the boys would put into their home or schoolwork,
but alas.
Seeing as none of the homework was “Find
Herobrine”, they really weren’t that interested.
Today, they were searching an area deep in
the misty forests, in the dead of night.
They fought off a few spiders and sword-wielding
skeletons - thankfully no Creepers - and kept
forging on into the darkness.
“It’s so creepy out here,” Lewis said
over his headset.
“Why did we have to come out here at night?
It’s way more dangerous with all the mobs!”
“But night is like the perfect time for
ghosts!”
Sydney retorted.
“You think a ghost is gonna start hanging
around in the middle of the day?
No way, it’s gotta be at night, man!”
And Lewis simply could not argue with such
incredibly sound logic.
They forged on, doing their typical methodical
search for any phenomena that one might generously
be able to describe as “Supernatural.”
So you can only imagine the excitement coursing
through them when Joseph discovered a strange,
dark cave that looked as though it had no
business being there.
While each held their own private reservations,
they all knew what they needed to do: Go inside
and investigate.
As they entered the cave, a few strange realizations
occurred to them - Such as the fact there
were seemingly no mobs down here.
A cave in the dead of night, surely there
should be some enemies, right?
Plus, the typical lightning implements, like
torches and lanterns, didn’t seem to offer
the same kind of illumination that they normally
would.
It was almost like the darkness was more oppressive
here, more tangible.
There was undeniably something eerie about
the whole setup, that much couldn’t be denied.
“You guys see anything?”
Lewis asked.
“No,” Joseph said, sounding oddly cautious,
as though he sensed something strange was
on the horizon.
Something that, perhaps, these boys shouldn’t
see.
“Yeah, I haven’t seen anything either,”
Sydney chimed in.
“Maybe we should--”
Joseph screamed, and the other two turned
their Minecraft avatars to look at him.
Joseph’s character had bumped into something,
some stranger in the cave.
An NPC design that looked oddly realistic
for something inhabiting the purposefully
lofi blocky world of Minecraft.
It seemed to have a dark, furry body, with
a canid, skull-like face, bearing a pair of
milky-white eyes that seemed to stare off
into nothingness.
Was this another mob?
Maybe something added in the latest patch?
If so, why wasn’t it attacking?
“What is that thing!?”
Lewis asked over his headset.
“I don’t know,” Joseph replied.
“It’s so creepy, though.”
Suddenly, a message appeared on the screen,
as though it had been typed and sent by another
player.
A player with the username “Mal0.”
The message read, “Hey, that isn’t very
nice.
You shouldn’t judge on appearances, kid.”
That certainly gave them pause.
So many things about this didn’t make sense:
It had all the hallmarks of an NPC, but apparently
it understood their voices and could send
messages.
It clearly wasn’t actually another player
in a conventional sense, but it didn’t attack
like your typical mob.
None of the boys could really make sense of
what they were dealing with here.
“Are you a hacker?”
Sydney asked.
“No,” Mal0 typed back.
“I’m just lonely, and a long way from
home.
It’s nice to have your company down here,
though.
I don’t get visitors often.”
“Have you ever heard of Herobrine?”
Lewis asked.
Mal0 typed back, “Is he a friend of yours?
You should introduce him to me.
I love making new friends.”
The three boys were, in some regards, rather
mature and polite for their ages, and so remained
civil with this bizarre, mysterious figure.
It was curious and inquisitive, asking them
questions about their school lives and their
friends.
It did seem earnestly happy for their company,
so it didn’t give any of them the sense
that it was a threat.
As the night drew on and the boys’ respective
parents told them it was time to log off and
get some shut-eye, Mal0 finally typed, “I’ve
really enjoyed hanging out with you kids.
Come back and visit me again tomorrow.
If you don’t, I’ll come visit you instead.”
None of the kids picked up on the probably
rather obvious Stranger Danger vibes of this
message, and instead, they went to bed, excited
and curious.
The next day, they met up on the playground
for a kind of State of the Union on the strange
phenomenon they had encountered the night
before.
“Do you think it has anything to do with
Herobrine?”
Lewis asked.
“Forget Herobrine,” Sydney replied, eliciting
gasps from the two others.
“All the other people have Herobrine, we
have something better.
Something only we’ve discovered.
We’ve got Mal0!”
Later that night, Joseph, who was probably
the most studious of the group, tried to do
a little background research on Mal0.
Everything seemed to turn up dead ends, aside
from one slightly shady-looking app called
“MalO ver1.0.0.”
Its description read:
“Never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again.
MalO is an exciting and interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued.
The anxiety of social situations can be nerve-racking,
but after just a few hours of MalO you will
soon forget all about those painful emotions
of disappointment.
Be part of the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute.
Remember, the more you participate, the more
MalO will engage you.
Your experience is completely up to you.
Absolutely NO ADS.
Enjoy!”
Weird.
So unless the thing they encountered on Minecraft
was some kind of weird viral marketing campaign
for the app, it was probably just a coincidence.
Maybe it was a popular character from Japan,
or something.
Either way, for the next several days, the
boys honored their promise.
They’d visit Mal0 in the cave every night
and chat, trying to tactfully get more information
out of it.
Though the best they could get on the entity’s
origin was the cryptic statement, “I’m
not usually here, but everyone wants a vacation
once in a while, don’t they?
We can just spend our whole life on a phone.”
They’d become so acclimated to Mal0 over
the days that they forgot what the entity
had said to them the very first day they met:
“Come back and visit me again tomorrow.
If you don’t, I’ll come visit you instead.”
But on the day that they didn’t come and
visit Mal0, because Miss Grayson had set a
particularly challenging piece of English
homework, they received a frightening reminder.
That very night, they all started receiving
strange texts on their phones.
As you can probably expect, they were all
photographs, each and every one depicting
some regular haunt that the boys all liked
to frequent, with one addition - Mal0’s
grinning skull face hiding somewhere in the
image, like some kind of demented parody of
Where’s Waldo.
The strangeness of this new development left
all the boys shaken, and they hopped back
onto Minecraft as quickly as possible to go
find and talk to Mal0 in its cave.
However, this time, the cave was empty, and
Mal0 was nowhere to be seen.
But the texts still didn’t stop.
They’d come in so frequently, with Mal0
getting closer to home - literally - in each
one.
The boys thought about telling their parents,
but would their parents believe them?
They’d probably lump Mal0 in with the same
tall tales of childhood imagination as Herobrine
and write it off as bored kids playing a prank,
even though, in this case, it was anything
but.
More photos arrived.
In these ones, Mal0 was right outside each
of the children’s homes, lurking, watching.
In some of the photos, they could see themselves
in the windows, going about their evening
business, having no idea of the creature lurking
just outside.
None of the boys felt like playing Minecraft
that night.
It wasn’t fun anymore.
Instead, they shut themselves up in their
room, closed and locked the windows, and pulled
down the blinds.
After checking under the beds with flashlights,
of course.
But still, more photos came in, all depicting
Mal0 getting closer, and closer, and closer…
Right about the time they were wondering whether
the scratching on the outside of their bedroom
doors was real or just a figment of their
imagination, another dark irony had occurred
to them: All this time trying to find something
supernatural, and in the very end, something
supernatural had instead found them…
Video games have come a long way over the
years.
We've gone from the days of Atari and "Pong"
to virtual reality headsets, PS5s, and massively
multiplayer online games where you can fight
horror movies villains, or wage war in a fantasy
land.
You can mine virtual minerals and avoid creepers
in "Minecraft," compete against people all
over the world in "Fortnite" and do whatever
it is people do in "Roblox."
Games used to be a pixelated hero battling
blobby monsters with no discernible facial
features, and now they have graphics so detailed
you can see the freckles on a protagonist's
face and each individual blade of grass.
But there's one thing that hasn't changed,
no matter how much progress games may make:
whenever a shiny new console comes out, everyone
wants to get their hands on it.
It was Christmas season in 1986, "Walk Like
an Egyptian" by the Bangles was at the top
of the charts, Eddie Murphy's "The Golden
Child" was the number one movie in America,
and hundreds of thousands of kids were writing
to Santa - and begging their parents - for
one thing: the Nintendo Entertainment System.
The NES was an 8-bit home video game console,
and the only place to journey through the
land of Hyrule in "The Legend of Zelda" or
help Samus hunt Space Pirates in "Metroid."
But with such an extreme demand for the system,
stores were selling out all over the country.
Anyone who didn't beat the crowds was doomed
to disappoint their kids with socks, with
less flashy toys like dolls or tiny plastic
trucks, or with boring, non-electric, violence-free
board games.
Well, board games are only violence-free if
you're not playing "Monopoly."
But back to 1986.
Beverly Harrington was a single mom, doing
her best to provide for her son, Jason, and
give him the Christmas he deserved.
She had been picking up extra shifts at the
local diner, making sure to save up all of
the extra money for a real Christmas tree
from the farm just out of town, for a beautiful
honey-baked ham, and, of course, for presents.
She knew that, though he was a shy kid and
would never demand it, Jason desperately wanted
to find an NES under the tree on Christmas
morning.
She got so absorbed in her work, so exhausted
from the extra shifts and trying to make everything
perfect, that she forgot to do her actual
shopping until the very last minute.
She woke up the morning of December 24 with
a start, her heart jumping into her throat.
She hadn't picked up Jason's present yet!
She threw on her coat and rushed out into
the snowy streets, making her way to the store
and saying a silent prayer that they would
still have one more NES in stock.
Lucky for her, they did!
Less lucky, two parents were already wrestling
for it, fighting each other with the raw animalistic
rage of two wolves competing for the same
piece of meat.
If she tried to grab it and join in, she could
get hurt, or the console could break apart.
She asked an employee if they had any in the
back, but she already knew the answer from
the exhausted look in his eyes.
There were no more in the back.
There were no more in town, or the next town
over, or the next town over from that.
Not only would she have to get Jason's present
at the very last minute, but she would also
have to get him something he didn't even want.
He would smile and thank her, but she knew
how sad it would make him to go back to school
and hear his friends bragging about their
Christmases.
She shoved her hands into the pockets of her
coat, and began her slow, sad march back through
the snow, trying to come up with what to do
next.
Then, something caught her eye, a brightly-colored
sign reading "Wondertaining Toys."
Beneath it, was a storefront she had never
seen before, and right there in the window,
a video game console.
It wasn't the NES, not exactly, but it looked
so much like it…
She couldn't help herself, she had to go inside
and get a better look.
The store was filled with toys, games, and
puzzles.
They were all inviting, with vivid packaging
and labels depicting children having fun,
but she had never seen any of them before.
Perhaps it was a new brand, and she was one
of the first people to happen upon the store?
It seemed odd for a toy store to open this
close to Christmas, rather than taking advantage
of the shopping season and opening earlier
in the year...But she couldn't dwell on that,
not when she was this close to a solution.
Toward the back of the store, she spotted
the video game console from the window.
The label read, "Pretendo."
So the resemblance to the NES was no coincidence,
this console was intended as a knockoff of
some kind.
She asked the sales clerk, a man with a strangely
wide, unmoving smile, if the console was capable
of running Nintendo games.
"You bet your bottom dollar!"
He replied.
"We don't carry those here, though.
But can I interest you in some of our Wondertainment
originals?
We have all kinds of games here, and they're
just as good or your money back!
There's a whole world inside each and every
one."
It wasn't what she'd set out to buy, but this
was clearly the best thing Beverly was going
to find this close to the holiday.
She paid the man for the Pretendo console
and a selection of the store's most popular
video games.
He even gift-wrapped it for her in a colorful
box, with a shiny red bow on top.
The next morning, Jason and Beverly sat in
the living room, sipping cocoa and opening
presents together.
She started small, with the classic pair of
new wool socks, and worked her way up to the
big box in the corner.
As Jason tore the paper off, his eyes lit
up with glee.
"Thank you, mom!
Thank you!"
He gave her a huge hug, then looked at her
with nearly manic excitement.
"Can I play it now?
Can I?"
She laughed and promised that after he helped
her clean up the wrapping paper, he could
play his new games.
She was just so glad he was happy with it.
He didn't care that it wasn't the name-brand
console, he knew that this gift was special.
So she was perfectly glad to let him enjoy
it, and she could get started on that ham
for later.
Jason plugged in his brand new Pretendo, and
looked through the games his mom had picked
out for him.
There was "Farmtastic!
Farming simulator", "Historical House Hunter",
"Magic Wizard Quest," "Super Fighters," and
one simply called, "Spooky."
It was emblazoned with the image of a cartoon
ghost in front of an abandoned cabin, and
it piqued Jason's interest.
He had always loved scary stories and legends
about ghosts and things that go bump in the
night.
He decided this would be his first game.
He placed the cartridge in the console and
hit the power button to turn it on.
As he clutched the controller in his hands,
he began to notice something strange.
His room, once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies, turned dark.
The light green walls became rotting wood.
And, for lack of a better way to describe
it, the entire world's resolution began to
shift.
If the world around him had graphics, they
were getting worse.
He could no longer see the screen depicting
the game's main menu, and in fact, the console
itself had vanished.
Somehow, he was standing in the haunted cabin
from the cover of the game.
He looked down at his hands and found the
controller still there.
So, not everything had changed...
Before he could think any more about this
strange new place he found himself in, he
heard the sound of ominous music, seemingly
coming from nowhere.
After a moment, he realized why the sound
of its melody filled him with dread...it was
the kind of music that always played in a
game when an enemy was getting close.
He had to move.
He took a step forward, and he moved through
the space as if it was a real house.
For the time being, it was.
Somehow, he was inside the game.
Which meant...the ghost was coming for him
soon.
He pressed a button on the controller to activate
a flashlight, and followed its beam through
the darkened cabin.
As he walked, looking for clues or any object
he could interact with, he could hear the
music getting louder.
Whatever was coming, it was getting closer.
The flashlight's beam illuminated a scrap
of paper on a small table.
He moved to take a closer look, and could
just barely make out what it said.
"They hide in the darkness.
Find the exit.
Don't stop moving.
"
He heard a sound behind him, and the music
reached a deafening volume.
He whirled around, and saw nothing but the
hall in front of him, bending around a corner.
He knew, from the heavy feeling in the pit
of his stomach and the music that threatened
to rupture his eardrums, that there was something
horrible waiting for him around that corner.
He froze for a moment, then remembered the
letter's words of warning, "don't stop moving."
He took a step toward the corner, then another,
and another.
He shone the light of the flashlight around
the corner, but there was nothing there.
No ghost, no monster.
Nothing.
And then he felt it.
A chill on the back of his neck.
He whirled around, and there it was.
The ghost of the cabin.
It was so much bigger than it had looked before,
wispy white form stretching up to the ceiling,
from wall to wall, its wide dark eyes and
gaping maw of a mouth inches from his own
face.
He screamed and instinctively swung the flashlight
at the spirit, cutting through it with a beam
of light.
The ghost let out a shriek and shrank away
from the glow.
That was it!
He just needed to keep the light on it, and
the ghost couldn't hurt him.
Jason was so thrilled by this little victory
that he didn't notice the boss music starting
to play again, growing louder and louder.
He didn't see the movement out of the corner
of his eye, the silvery pale figure of a woman
stepping out of a portrait on the wall.
All he felt was a sudden, overwhelming cold,
like ice in his veins, and then everything
went black.
He opened his eyes back in his bedroom, looking
at a dark screen with the words GAME OVER
written in dripping red font.
He couldn't tell for a moment if that had
been real or a dream, but either way, he only
wanted to do one thing: tell his mom.
Beverly listened to her son's story, and couldn't
help but write it off as the overactive imagination
of a child.
But still, she humored him and agreed to try
the console for herself and see what happened.
Choosing at random, she selected "Farmtastic!"
and pressed "play."
All of a sudden, she felt the heat of the
sun on her face, heard the mooing of cows,
and smelled fresh-cut hay.
She was steering a tractor through a wide-open
field, where a moment ago she had been standing
in her house in the dead of winter.
Jason shut off the game, pulling her back
into reality, and as Beverly gaped in shock,
Jason said "Best!
Present!
EVER!"
Unfortunately for Jason, word was already
spreading about the Pretendo, all the way
to the SCP Foundation.
The console, and all other consoles that the
Foundation could track down, were seized and
designated SCP-591.
SCP-591 is a line of video game consoles originally
developed as a counterfeit of the Nintendo
Entertainment System, before being bought
and distributed by Doctor Wondertainment,
a toy company responsible for a wide variety
of anomalous objects contained by the Foundation
over the years.
The console is capable of playing NES titles
as well as games from Doctor Wondertainment's
original lineup of 8-bit games, many of which
the Foundation has in its possession as well.
Some of the titles in the SCP Foundation library
include, but are not limited to, arcade shooter
"Whap 'Em!", platformer "Dusky's Adventures
in Staedland," survival horror game "You Can
Do That on Television," puzzle game "WWI Ace
Trench Digger," music/racing game "Led Zeppelin
Air Racers," fightings games "Super Kick Karate"
and "Super Kick Karate 2010," and the educational
game "Reading Rainbow Sit and Listen."
Whenever one of the official Doctor Wondertainment
cartridges is inserted into the console and
activated, it results in a localized CK-class
reality restructuring scenario, which rearranges
reality in the immediate area to resemble
the game's setting.
The player inside of the game's affected radius
will take on the role of the game's protagonist,
and navigate the events of the game until
they either win or the console is deactivated.
Don't worry, this isn't one of those "if you
die in the game you die in real life" scenarios.
If the player happens to be a less than adept
gamer, they will simply respawn or start at
the beginning of the game like any video game
character would.
That doesn't, however, mean that SCP-591 isn't
dangerous.
Like any piece of vintage technology, the
components of the Pretendo system have degraded
over time, their functionality steadily decreasing.
For an ordinary game console, this would be
a simple inconvenience, something that would
impact the quality of the graphics or the
responsiveness of the controls.
It would be annoying, and maybe eventually
unplayable, but otherwise harmless.
For the Pretendo, however, this degradation
has had catastrophic effects.
When a game cartridge is inserted into SCP-591,
there is now a chance of the CK-class reality
restructuring scenario going wrong, and resulting
in a ZK-class reality failure scenario instead.
Essentially, instead of just transporting
the player into the world of the game, reality
will crumble in the designated area and the
laws of time, space, and physics will be bent
or even broken.
While the CK-class scenarios dissipate as
soon as the console is deactivated, the ZK-class
scenarios refuse to play by the rules.
They remain in place wherever they first manifested,
seemingly permanently.
The ZK-class scenarios were first observed
during play-testing by the research staff
assigned to SCP-591.
After learning about the nature of the Pretendo
game system, Dr. Furakawa has volunteered
as a test subject, specifically requesting
that he be given the chance to play the Dr.
Wondertainment title "The Legend of Sword
Master," because, quote, "It just looks really
cool."
This particular game came with not just the
cartridge, but a special sword-shaped controller,
to be used during the sword fight sequences.
Dr. Furakawa stepped into the containment
cell where one instance of SCP-591 had been
placed, with his chosen game cartridge and
controller waiting for him.
As soon as he inserted the cartridge into
the console and pressed the "start" button,
the room around him began to transform, reality
itself warping and reshaping to fit the world
of the game.
Fluorescent lights and stark white walls were
replaced by pixelated trees, and a winding
cobblestone path leading to a massive stone
castle.
The first enemy, a knight in black armor,
leaped into frame, and Dr. Furakawa raised
his sword, ready for combat.
But before he had a chance to deal the first
blow, it became clear that something wasn't
right.
The enemy knight suddenly disappeared, glitching
out of sight.
The cobblestones slowly began to drift into
the air, and so did Dr. Furakawa.
Just as suddenly as he lifted off, he dropped
back to the ground with a heavy thud.
Gravity was rapidly fluctuating, and he could
scarcely keep his balance.
In front of him, he could see random cubic
structures popping up out of nowhere, made
up of wood, stone, and ice.
"End the game!"
He called out desperately.
"Pull the plug, someone, please!"
Outside, one of the researchers watching the
experiment cut the power to the console, but
nothing happened.
The world refused to return to normal.
Security officers entered the area, and attempted
to remove Dr. Furakawa, but found that his
body still resembled an 8-bit video game character.
When they attempted to drag him out of the
ZK-class zone, he cried out in pain as his
body began to dissolve into static.
They had turned off the console, but they
were unable to pull him out.
The rest of the research team, horrified by
what they had witnessed, began to take measurements
of the reality failure scenario from outside
of the room.
The area now displayed a complete absence
of naturally occurring radiation, including
cosmic background radiation.
There was also evidence of time dilation,
reduction of light speed, and the gravity
fluctuations that Dr. Furakawa had first noticed.
With no way to remove Furakawa from this broken
reality, the area would have to be sealed
off, and he would be left inside.
There was no other option.
So, they constructed a concrete dome around
the testing site, and relocated the remaining
instances of SCP-591.
From that point on, testing was only conducted
using D-Class, no matter how much research
staff loved video games, or how vehemently
they insisted that they were "willing to roll
the dice."
They were barred from testing and encouraged
to pick up a VR headset for a much lower-risk
immersive gaming experience.
Over the years of testing following the Dr.
Furakawa incident, four more ZK-class scenarios
were created and contained.
Some of the individuals survived the incident
but were physically altered so greatly that
they would not be able to survive outside
of the ZK-class reality failure.
The only people who survived were unable to
readjust to their lives, continuing to live
as the main character of the game they were
playing.
At this point, testing was officially suspended
indefinitely, due not only to the loss of
human life but also the unpredictable and
highly dangerous nature of the damage being
done to reality on such a grand scale.
All instances of SCP-591 confiscated by the
Foundation are kept in a storage containment
vault, kept separate from any civilians or
their infrastructure by a distance of at least
500m.
It is also kept separate from other Foundation-controlled
containment facilities.
Unless it is being used for official, approved
testing by Level-3 staff, it is to remain
deactivated at all times.
Any ZK-class scenarios created by an instance
of SCP-591 will be contained via the construction
of a closed concrete dome, and given the designation
of Sector-W#.
Sectors W1 through W5, the currently existing
ZK-class scenarios, are monitored remotely
and kept highly classified.
Any personnel or test subjects located inside
one of these sectors will remain there indefinitely,
and be officially considered lost in action.
Any additional instances of SCP-591 located
in civilian stores, households, or any public
place are to be removed and contained immediately.
As the years have gone by, testing has indicated
a steady increase in the rake of a ZK-class
scenario being generated from a CK-class scenario.
Where it was once only a 1% chance, there
is now a 32% chance.
According to Wondertainment company records,
seized during a Foundation raid of one of
their toy factories, there are still plenty
of SCP-591 instances out there in the wild,
just waiting for some unsuspecting gamer to
fire them up and get lost in the story, literally.
If the documents found are accurate, there
are around 243 consoles and 1,300 consoles
still in circulation.
These also may or may not include a "Pocket
Pretendo" model that was developed as a prototype
but never officially released on the market.
If it was, and the chaos of the Pretendo system
is available in a portable form...well, it's
best not to think about that for too long.
The Foundation is doing its best to track
down the remaining Pretendo systems, but there
is no way to know for sure what distant corners
of the world they've made their way to.
So, when you're picking up a shiny new game
console, or a nostalgic vintage model to relive
some of your favorite childhood memories with,
take an extra close look at the label and
make sure you're getting the real thing.
Because if you're not careful...it just might
be Game Over.
It's frightening to think about how many people
go missing each year.
Approximately 1,600 individuals mysteriously
vanish each year in national parks alone.
One moment they're there, making their way
down a hiking trail or stopping for a granola
bar by a lake,
and the next, they're gone.
Missing people are an unfortunate fact of
life, one we all just try to put out of our
minds as we silently hope we, and those we
know and love,
will be fortunate enough to avoid joining
the ranks of the lost.
But some places, some very strange, obscure
places, nestled in the quiet countryside and
tucked away under blankets of fog,
lose so many people that it becomes, well,
anomalous.
One particular town, a seemingly innocuous
place with a thriving tourism industry was
the site of so many unexplained disappearances
that it drew the attention of The SCP Foundation.
They dispatched a team to enter the town,
to gather as many facts and figures as they
could,
and to see what exactly had become of these
missing people.
Leading this team was none other than the
sometimes fearless, often shameless, Dr. Jack
Bright.
How did the infamous Dr. Bright get here?
Well, for many employees of the SCP Foundation,
leading a task force to investigate a new
potentially anomalous location would be a
promotion,
or a welcome diversion from yet another round
of testing to see if maybe something will
finally destroy SCP-682.
But in this particular case, it was a matter
of discipline.
After Dr. Bright was caught giving SCP-999
a triple-shot of espresso, "just to see what
would happen,"
he was assigned to field work as part of his
punishment.
For the record, what happened was SCP-999
ricocheting off of the walls at such high
speed and intensity
that it broke several windows, damaged the
ceiling, and knocked out the power for half
of the Site.
And, so, Dr. Bright found himself with a task
force of Foundation operatives trudging reluctantly
through beautiful but boring rural New England,
toward the town of interest.
As he drove down the winding road, grumbling
to himself and wishing he could be anywhere
else,
he spotted the sign marking their intended
destination: "Welcome to Silent Hill."
Up ahead, a thick fog rolling off the lake
covered the town in a dim gray blur.
He couldn't make out anything through the
unnaturally dense haze.
He squinted and turned on the high beams,
but the light did nothing to cut through the
fog,
bouncing off of it like a billowing curtain
of white.
Just as they passed the sign, the van began
to slow rapidly, its engine sputtering and
grinding as the vehicle skidded to a sudden
stop.
"Dammit!"
Dr. Bright thumped the steering wheel in frustration.
"Any of you know how to fix a car?"
He looked at the team of operatives in the
back seat.
They all shrugged noncommittally.
The only thing worse than wandering into that
fog would be sitting in the broken-down van
watching Tweedledum and Tweedledumber try
to attend to the failing engine.
His private joke almost lifted his mood, but
not quite.
He popped open the door and stepped out into
the cold, damp air.
"Well, figure it out.
I'm gonna take a look around."
Dr. Bright shoved his hands into his pockets,
and, not knowing what might wait on the other
side, began his walk into Silent Hill.
With each step, he ruminated on the events
that had gotten him here.
Where did those guys at the Foundation get
off, disciplining him like an unruly child?
Sure, he liked his pranks.
He enjoyed a good joke, and maybe sometimes
he took it just a little bit too far,
but he'd like to see them confront the existential
dread of immortality without needing a humorous
outlet every now and then.
They'd crack under the pressure without a
release of some kind, so what gave them the
right to put him,
a brilliant if unconventional mind, in some
kind of glorified time out?
He scoffed out loud to himself, and the sound
echoed in the vacant streets.
The sheer emptiness of it all snapped him
out of his self-pity, and for the first time
he looked up to take in his surroundings.
The stubborn fog refused to dissipate, no
matter how far he walked,
but at least he could make out the shapes
of buildings now, of parked cars on the side
of the road.
No, not parked.
Wrecked, abandoned, left to rust.
He scanned the fog for human silhouettes,
listened for voices, for any signs of life.
But there was no one.
He approached a building, and found it dilapidated,
rotted wood collapsing in on itself, windows
cracked, door boarded up tight.
The buildings next to it looked very much
the same.
What the hell?
He was sent to investigate recent disappearances,
but this town looked as if its entire population
had vanished decades ago.
Or, he thought with a small shudder, all decided
to leave in a hurry.
What could have driven them out?
"Okay, that's it.
I'm done," Dr. Bright remarked, turning a
swift 180 degrees and preparing to go back
the way he came.
As he did, though, he froze.
Where there had once been continuous, unbroken
road,
the street now ended in a jagged edge, a deep,
dark chasm the only thing that waited beyond.
It was too broad to jump across, and he couldn't
see another road out of town.
"Hey guys?" he called out, hoping to draw
the attention of one of the men he had left
with the van.
"A little help over here?"
But there was no response.
"Hello?!" he shouted again, louder this time.
When no one answered, he repeated himself
again and again with increasing desperation,
his voice growing hoarse from the effort.
Had they somehow fixed the van and left him
there?
Had they fallen into the chasm where the road
once was and been killed on impact?
There was no rational explanation for what
was at play here, but, as the consciousness
of a man living inside of an ancient amulet
reminded himself,
he very rarely encountered rational things
in his life.
There had to be a way out; he just had to
find it.
If he couldn't go back?
Well, he would just have to keep moving forward.
On through the winding labyrinth of the street,
through the maze of crumbling buildings, looking
for any signs of life.
He followed a natural bend in the road and
suddenly found himself wedged between two
buildings, down a narrow, claustrophobic alley.
It seemed that this place didn't feel much
like playing by the ordinary rules of time
and space.
And while Dr. Bright could usually appreciate
a rulebreaker, being a little rebellious himself,
this uncertainty was putting him on edge.
His breaths came in shallow gasps,
his chest tight with apprehension.
As he turned in a circle, looking for the
best way out, he heard a sound behind him,
the first noise he had heard other than his
own breathing in quite some time.
It was the soft, plodding sound of uneven
footsteps.
Like someone small, walking with a limp.
He whirled around to face the noise and saw
what he might have mistaken for a child, until
he got a proper look at it.
The thing that was steadily approaching him
was small and humanoid in shape,
but that was where the similarities to a human
being ended.
Its skin was a pale, mottled gray, the shade
of a body fished out of a river after weeks
of bloating and decay.
Its mouth was a twisted, gaping hole, more
like a wound than a mouth,
and in place of its eyes were a pair of slits
in the pale flesh.
It stumbled as it walked, like it was still
learning how,
but this childish ineptitude did nothing to
distract from the creature's menace.
As it advanced toward Dr. Bright, he saw the
glint of something metal.
In the creature's gnarled fist, it held a
rusty knife.
As it got closer, it slashed haphazardly in
his direction, and its mouth opened wider
to let out a chilling high-pitched giggle.
This thing was prepared to carve him up and
enjoy every second of the job.
As he took in the sight of the horrible grey
child in front of him, Dr. Bright had been
frozen to the spot,
unable to force his legs to carry him away.
But the sight of the knife, the grim realization
of just exactly what this thing had in store
for him, shocked him back to life.
He grabbed a wooden beam leaning against the
nearest wall and threw it at the little monster,
knocking it onto its back.
It was immobilized just long enough for Dr.
Bright to get his bearings, turn, and run
back toward the wider street.
As he did, he could hear that gleeful laughter
as the creature climbed back to its feet,
and it only pushed him to run faster.
When he could no longer hear the little footsteps
or the warped giggles of the grey child, Dr.
Bright stopped to catch his breath.
So, it seemed like there was life in Silent
Hill after all.
There just wasn't human life.
There was silence for a moment, nothing but
Dr. Bright's heart pounding in his head as
he bent over his knees and silently cursed
himself for not exercising this body more
often.
Then, the shrill cry of an air raid siren
ripped through the foggy air,
and for a moment, his heart stopped.
What the hell did that sound mean?
He stood up, inspecting his surroundings for
signs of danger, for...what?
A tornado?
A bomb?
He wasn't sure, but nothing could have prepared
him for what he saw next.
The entire landscape had shifted around him
in an instant.
He was unsure of how exactly to describe it,
except to say that the world had gotten darker,
more dangerous.
Where the streets had been lit by dim, grey
sunlight filtered through the haze,
there was now darkness, save for an occasional
street lamp with a flickering red bulb.
He couldn't be sure if it was a trick of the
light, but he could swear there was blood
staining the street,
smeared across the brick walls of the buildings
on either side.
The town had been ominous before, but now?
It was like something out of a nightmare.
And all the while, the siren continued to
blare, warning of a danger he could not see.
He needed to find shelter.
That was it.
From what, he didn't know,
but whatever was coming couldn't be good.
Dr. Bright ran to the nearest door, twisting
the knob, trying to yank it open, but it wouldn't
budge.
The hinges were rusted shut, and there was
no time to try and force them open.
He tried another door.
And another.
It was as if the houses knew to try and keep
him out, to keep him exposed and vulnerable
on the outside.
Finally, he reached a two-story house with
peeling white paint and a mahogany door, one
that looked so familiar but that he couldn't
quite place.
When he turned the knob, the door creaked
open with ease, and he quickly raced inside,
slammed the door shut behind him, and locked
it.
As Dr. Bright slumped against the door, overtaken
with exhaustion, an intrusive thought made
his stomach drop.
Was he alone in this house?
Had he really found shelter,
or had he just shut himself inside with something
even worse than what waited out there?
In the silence, he could swear he heard the
quiet thumping of a pulse, but he couldn't
tell if it was his own or the house's beating
heart.
He couldn't just stay standing here, dreaming
up all the horrors that might be waiting.
He needed to gather data, investigate his
surroundings, and come up with potential solutions.
He needed to be a scientist.
On unsteady legs, Dr. Bright began to walk
the halls of the house, taking in his surroundings
properly for the first time.
It was dusty and dark, a place left vacant
for quite some time, but there were signs
of a life once lived within the house's walls.
A rocking horse in the corner, a shelf full
of well-worn books.
The titles scratched an itch in his brain,
memories he hadn't touched in decades.
Strange, that so many of the books in this
house would remind him of the pages he once
flipped through, staying inside to read while
his brother played in the yard outside.
His brother…
Dr. Bright swallowed the lump in his throat
at the thought of TJ.
No use going down that path, not right now.
He continued his walk through the house, taking
in the cobwebs, the couch covered with plastic,
the coffee table, and the tv set.
Along the hall leading to the bathroom, there
were rows of family pictures hanging in neat
little frames.
He stopped to take a look, wondering what
sort of family had once lived here.
As his eyes fell on the first photograph,
his blood turned to ice in his veins.
A boy looked out from within the frame, a
familiar boy with a mop of red hair, a freckled
nose, and kind, smiling eyes.
"No..."
Dr. Bright whispered to himself.
But there was no denying it.
It was TJ.
His brother,
somehow, looking at him from inside a photograph
in an abandoned house in Silent Hill.
Next, there was a photo of TJ and an older
man.
Dr. Bright's stomach turned.
Their father.
Every photograph was of his family, the family
he would never know again, not the way they
were.
And there, in one photo in the middle, TJ
and his father were joined by another figure,
one with the face scratched out of the picture.
He knew, though he couldn't see for certain,
that it was him, removed from the family photo
by force.
The bond between them all forever broken.
TJ's eyes in the picture seemed filled with
tears, heartbroken.
His father glowered out of the frame at him,
pure hatred in his gaze.
He couldn't look anymore and turned away.
On the opposite wall, another photograph of
TJ was waiting.
Dr. Bright felt bile rising in his throat.
He recognized this photo, he saw it sometimes
when he closed his eyes at night.
It was a picture taken with SCP-978, the Desire
Camera,
the anomalous camera that reveals its subject's
innermost desires.
In the photo, TJ's hands were pressed to the
lens, like an animal clawing at the boundaries
of its cage.
His eyes were filled with tears, spilling
over and streaming down his cheeks.
And his mouth was wide open in an endless
scream of fear and agony.
This, Dr. Bright knew, was the wordless scream
inside his brother's mind at all times, after
so much testing with the Foundation had destroyed
him.
"I tried to help you..." he whispered to the
picture.
"I did what I could to, take the pain away..."
He trailed off, the words dying in his throat,
as the sound of a heavy, rattling breath came
from the room at the end of the hall.
It was a thick, wheezing sound, like a death
rattle a dozen times over.
He didn't want to see what was making the
noise, but, as if in a trance, he found his
feet carrying him toward it.
He crossed the threshold of what should have
been the kitchen, but instead found himself
in a dimly lit hospital.
The air smelled of formaldehyde and dried
vomit, the steady beep of a heart monitor
joining the chorus of heavy, agonizing breathing.
At the end of the long hall there was one
single room, the door standing slightly ajar.
With slow, agonizing steps, Dr. Bright approached
the room.
The breathing grew louder and louder, the
beep of the heart monitor almost deafening
in his ears.
He could barely separate the strange breathing
from his own, finding his breaths coming in
time with the painful, rattling sound.
He pushed the door open and saw a figure lying
in a hospital bed.
It was once human, but it could only be described
now as a conglomerate of disease and pain.
On top of the figure's head, thinning in patches
but still recognizable, was a shock of red
hair.
"No...TJ...no-" Dr. Bright's voice broke off
in a sob at the sight.
The thing that was once his brother turned,
seeking the sound of his voice though he could
not see.
"Isn't this what you wanted?"
A low voice rumbled behind him.
Dr. Bright whirled around to see a dark shadow,
red eyes glowing in the low light.
It moved like a wisp of black smoke, but he
knew that voice well enough to tell just who
it was.
His father.
"You let them do this to him."
"I didn't...I didn't mean for this to happen..."
Dr. Bright stammered.
"You didn't care!"
the demon father roared, and the lightbulb
above their heads flared and burst, sending
shards of glass scattering everywhere.
"All he ever did was help people, to heal
pain.
And all you ever did was cause it."
Dr. Bright found the strength to move, running
through the doorway, sending the shape of
his father in every direction as the smell
of sulfur and blood filled his nose.
"I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry."
He wept as he ran, hearing his father's agonized
cries,
his brother's labored breathing, as he tore
back down the hospital hall.
As he did, hands began to reach through the
walls, the floor, the ceiling.
They were rotting, flesh gone green and stiff.
Arms followed the hands, then shoulders, then
faces.
He recognized D-Class uniforms, lab coats,
face after familiar face.
Everyone who had ever worn the amulet, he
realized with a sudden wave of nausea.
Everyone whose body he had taken, who he had
killed so that he could live.
"This is what you do."
He could hear his father's voice just behind
him, the curls of black smoke nipping at his
heels.
"What kind of creature kills to live?
Something that deserves to die.
But you can't, can you?
You're a parasite, sucking all of the good
and the life from this world until it's an
empty husk, just like you."
The living graveyard of victims reached for
Dr. Bright, tearing at his clothes as he passed
them.
There were so many...he'd never realized how
many until he saw them all lined up like this.
"I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry," he said to every face he passed,
but there was no forgiveness in their dead
eyes.
His father's voice fell silent, but there
was no reprieve.
Instead, there was the sound of heavy footsteps
pursuing him, the grating shriek of a large
bladed weapon dragging along the ground.
Dr. Bright glanced over his shoulder and saw
a massive, hulking figure, like a man but
with a jagged metal pyramid covering his head.
He was clad in blood-stained clothing, and
approaching Dr. Bright with the casual menace
of something that had killed endless times
before, and was ready to do it again.
It didn't care to chase him, it knew it would
eventually catch up.
As he looked at the figure, it began to warp,
to change.
It morphed into something else...something
he recognized.
A man, with black hair and grey eyes that
revealed nothing but cold malice.
A body, covered in tattoos of the arcane and
the occult, of merciless grinning faces belonging
to ancient monsters.
And in his hand, a long bladed weapon, a curved
sword perfectly engineered for battle.
It was impossible, he should be contained,
but there he was.
SCP-076-2, looking at Dr. Bright the same
way he had on the day he had first worn the
amulet.
The day he became an abomination.
The sound of his brother's breathing grew
louder, his fathers voice bellowing in his
mind,
and he felt the grasp of the fallen Foundation
employees at his back.
It was all too much, too many reminders of
every failure, every hurt.
Dr. Bright collapsed to his knees, and bared
his neck to Able in submission.
"You're right.
I should be punished.
I've done nothing but hurt, and kill, and
destroy everything I touch.
Just punish me.
Please...I'm begging you."
Then, something Dr. Bright never could have
expected.
The figure that looked like Able but couldn't
be began to laugh, a cruel, hollow sound.
"No."
It said, in a voice that sounded like a chorus
of hundreds.
"We will release you.
Nothing we can do here will ever be worse
than the eternity of torment that stretches
before you.
Good luck to you...Dr. Bright."
Jack Bright let out a wail of agony, reaching
out to Able with pleading hands as the entity
turned
and slowly walked away, leaving him there
alone with the hell that was his thoughts.
Then, everything faded to black.
"Dr. Bright?
Dr. Bright?!"
The sound of one of the team members brought
Dr. Bright back to consciousness, and he opened
his eyes.
He was lying on his side on the same road
he had walked along before, right next to
the sign welcoming the group to Silent Hill.
"You're all...still here?" he asked, weakly.
"What do you mean?"
The man looked puzzled.
"We parked the van, you got out, you fell
down, and we've been trying to wake you up."
"How long was I out...?"
Dr. Bright's vision swam as he tried to wrap
his mind around the information.
"I dunno, about ten minutes?"
SCP-096, the Shy Guy, woke up in an unfamiliar
room without a thought in its head.
However, one thing quickly occurred to it:
This was not its containment chamber.
No, the solid steel cube that had kept it
locked up for decades now didn’t have a
front desk, or walls covered in strange, childlike
murals, or tinny party music playing over
old speakers.
Wherever SCP-096 had found itself, it certainly
wasn’t the place it’d come to call home.
If it could read, it would have registered
the word’s behind the front desk, painted
onto the wall: Banban’s Kindergarten - Where
joy comes alive!
Little did 096 know, something really did
come to life here at Banban’s kindergarten,
but it wasn’t definitely joy.
SCP-096 was typically used to a much more
confined space, so presented with so much
strange freedom, its natural instinct was
to wander around, whimpering quietly to itself.
This place was certainly peculiar, with multiple
large, reinforced doors, each one having a
large, red button fixed to the wall above
them.
A strange green creature was painted on the
wall, with an affixed speech bubble that read,
“Jumbo Josh says, ‘Eat fruits and vegetables
if you want to be strong like me!’”
Though 096 paid no mind to such things.
This place looked like an SCP Foundation containment
facility mixed with an off-brand Chuck E Cheese,
and some tiny part of the Shy Guy’s dim
and dismal brain wanted to see more of it.
What other secrets could it hold?
The Shy Guy pressed one of the big red buttons,
causing the doors to open underneath it.
There was a faint sound of childish laughter
somewhere down the distant hall.
How had it ever found its way to such a strange
place?
The deeper the Shy Guy wandered, the more
strange murals it saw on the wall.
There was one for a large, orange cartoon
jellyfish with one staring eye, where the
speech bubble read, “Stinger Flynn says,
‘Having many arms allows me to help a lot
of people.’”
Then, a squat, blue gorilla-like creature
with sharp lower teeth, the speech bubble
reading, “Captain Fiddles says, ’Ooga
Booga!
Booga ooga!’”
A White, feminine, cat-like creature had the
speech bubble, “Banbaleena says, ‘Kindness
is free, so sprinkle it everywhere.’”
A misshapen, pink bird creature had the speech
bubble, “Opila Bird says, ‘Laughter is
the best medicine, so make sure to smile.’”
And of course, most importantly of all, presiding
over the “creativity room”, was a mural
of a grinning red creature wearing a pair
of party hats on his head like horns.
His speech bubble read, “Banban says, ‘Sharing
is caring.
Your pancreas is mine!’”
A whiteboard not far from this mural had the
words, “RUN FOR YOUR LIVES!”
hastily scrawled onto it.
To anyone but the Shy Guy, who had no point
of reference, this was clearly not a normal
Kindergarten.
As the Shy Guy passed into the hallway, slowly
lumbering along, it suddenly felt an intense
spike of burning pain right through its forehead.
Rising like a fever pitch, the Shy Guy’s
subdued whimpers quickly escalated into horrifying
wails of animal rage.
This could only mean one thing: Somewhere,
something had made the terrible mistake of
gazing at the Shy Guy’s face.
In fact, not ten feet away, the unfortunate
Opila Bird had made that very mistake.
It typically peeked out from behind one of
the hallway’s pillars to get a good look
at any potential intruders, or new prey wandering
into its midst.
But this time, the beastly bird’s curiosity
had taken it from predator to prey itself.
Though it wouldn’t realize this until it
was already too late.
As the mutant bird creature skittered back
into the cavernous hall filled with plastic
trees and an underwhelming play area, the
Shy Guy came galloping after it on all fours,
roaring with fury.
The Opila Bird was shocked to see the creature
giving chase - This doesn’t make sense,
I’m meant to chase you, you’re not meant
to chase me!
But things are rarely fair when it comes to
the Shy Guy - arguably one of the most dangerous
Euclid-class creatures ever kept in Foundation
containment.
The Opila Bird flapped desperately towards
the boarded-up escape hatch, but the Shy Guy
was so much faster.
It grabbed hold of the bird, gripping it in
its iron clutches, and began to stretch open
its bottom jaw with a blood-curdling roar.
We’ll spare you the details of what happened
next, but suffice to say, little more than
a handful of feathers were left.
After finishing off the Opila Bird, the Shy
Guy reverted from rage back to pitiful sadness.
This place was no better than the SCP Foundation
- There were still creatures here to look
at its face and drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress!
It was horrible.
The Shy Guy needed to find a way to hide himself
away again, so he decided to tear away the
planks covering up the escape hatch and lope
down the narrow hall.
In there, the Shy Guy actually found something
to its liking: Two platforms, one on either
side of the room, with what seemed to be a
deep, dark chasm between the two.
For most, there was an electrical lift system
for carrying them between the platforms, but
the Shy Guy had no interest in the platforms
- He only sought the darkness below, where
nobody could see his face.
That would suit him just fine.
The Shy Guy jumped over the guard rail and
plummeted down below into the dark.
Feeling the air against its cold, gray skin
as it fell felt wonderful.
It dared to think that it might even find
solace in this deep, dark place, but as soon
as it hit something solid - Some kind of metal
lift system - alarms went off, and flashing
red lights soon made everything down there
in the darkness visible.
To be exposed like this while it thought it
was hidden was the dreaded Shy Guy’s worst
nightmare.
Little did he know, he would soon become the
worst nightmare of a number of other beasts.
As the Shy Guy crawled off the metal platform,
hoping that perhaps it could find another
place to hide down here, its hands and feet
splashed into shallow water.
Had something sprung a leak down here?
The Shy Guy began wandering the half-dark
as the water of this flooded sub-basement
area, having no idea that another creature
was already sneaking up behind it, getting
ready to strike.
Before 096 could even react, several whip-like
orange tentacles wrapped around its limbs
and began delivering an agonizing shock through
its body.
More tentacles came in soon after, wrapping
around the Shy Guy’s body and face, delivering
shock after shock after shock with its millions
of tiny, venomous stinger barbs.
For a second, it seemed like the surprise
attack might actually be able to subdue the
monster, but little did the Shy Guy’s attacker
- the monstrous real Stinger Flynn - know,
that attacking it was just another way to
activate its infamous rage state.
The second that Stinger Flynn relented, even
for just a moment, the Shy Guy grabbed him
by the tentacles and slammed him into the
watery floor, again and again and again, until
the grip of his tentacles loosened around
the Shy Guy’s body, and he was defenseless.
With Stinger panicked and immobilized, the
Shy Guy released the full force of his supernatural
fury, striking the demonic jellyfish with
his fists until what was left couldn’t be
distinguished from the water it used to be
floating in.
Stinger Flynn had been completely annihilated.
The Shy Guy, once again temporarily returned
to a state of calm, wandered out of this watery
basement into a nearby hallway, where everything
was bright and dry.
The walls were painted in garish, childlike
drawings of a jungle with janky-looking animals.
The Shy Guy paid no mind to any of it - All
he wanted was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone, and away from the prying
eyes of all these freaks.
This dream was short-lived, because as soon
as the Shy Guy found a new room - A wide-open
auditorium filled with inflatable jungle trees,
like a crude play area - he was being stalked
yet again.
A powerful, muscular predator, with veins
stretching over its bulging muscles and blue
skin.
It knew that this intruder had already killed
two of its fellow Garten dwellers, but this
time, it would put this spindly, pale stranger
in its place.
The Shy Guy heard something rumbling towards
it from behind, and turned upon hearing the
bloodcurdling war cry of “Ooga booga, booga
ooga!”
It was the gorilla-like Captain Fiddles, with
strands of saliva hanging from his tusks.
He leaped onto the Shy Guy and began pounding
into its hideous face with his huge, blue
fists.
Captain Fiddles would destroy the Shy Guy,
pound him into the concrete until he stopped
moving.
The one thing that Captain Fiddles didn’t
expect was for the Shy Guy to start fighting
back - And he was about to learn the hard
truth that the Shy Guy could fight a lot harder
than him.
The SCP’s spindly but immensely powerful
arms grabbed Captain Fiddles by the shoulders
and threw him into the wall, causing huge
cracks to crawl up toward the ceiling.
Before Captain Fiddles could even think about
wrenching himself free, the Shy Guy leaped
to his feet and bounded over to him.
The Shy Guy grabbed Captain Fiddles by the
ankles and ripped him out of the wall, letting
his body drop to the floor and then unleashing
hell upon him.
Captain Fiddles would have begged for mercy,
if he wasn’t already dead.
Before the Shy Guy could even begin to calm
down, a trap door opened in the floor beneath
him, dropping him into a new area: A multi-colored
maze, where 096 was trapped like a helpless
rat…
With the body count of an atom bomb.
Once again, the Shy Guy didn’t need to go
looking for trouble, because trouble was already
on its way: The pure white, catlike Banbaleena
pounced from a sharp corner in the maze, claws
bared.
She jumped onto the Shy Guy, latching onto
him and clawing at him, trying to scratch
his nightmare of a face.
If the Shy Guy had ever possessed anything
resembling patience, it would have run out
long before now.
It grabbed Banbaleena, shrugging off the pain
of her claws, and tossed her into the darkness
high above.
She flew off with a cat-like yowl and hit
some distant ceiling with a crunch.
Suffice to say, she wouldn’t be back to
bother the Shy Guy again.
Tired and angry, the pale abomination didn’t
feel like wandering through a maze.
Instead, it just charged straight through,
destroying colorful wall after colorful wall.
When it encountered whatever was behind this
extremely frustrating afternoon, it would
destroy it with extreme prejudice.
That was almost a certainty.
After breaking through one more wall, the
Shy Guy tumbled out into a storage room, where
a grinning red creature was waiting for him
- Wearing two party hats on top of his head.
This was no mere lackey, it was Banban himself,
the one behind this nightmarish kindergarten.
He stared right into the Shy Guy’s face
with no fear at all, almost like he knew something
the Shy Guy didn’t.
And it was true - He had no plan to fight
the Shy Guy himself.
He’d brought a champion with him.
As the Shy Guy started to scream in rage,
all the boxes behind Banban tumbled out of
the way as a huge figure rose.
A behemoth, at least fifty feet tall, with
green skin, giant teeth, and huge, staring
eyes.
It was Jumbo Josh, and if the Shy Guy wanted
to graduate from this nightmare kindergarten,
it would need to defeat him and Banban.
Shy Guy growled, digging its claws into the
ground and preparing to charge forward.
Challenge accepted.
Did you hear that not so long ago, a five-year-old
boy went up against twelve of Russia’s greatest
chess grandmasters - And do you know what
happened?
He lost every single match.
That’s because winning at chess, dear viewers,
isn’t easy.
Chess is an ancient game of strategy, cunning,
and skill.
It’s not just about thinking one step ahead
of your opponent, that’s not going to be
enough.
Make a wrong prediction and you could end
up sacrificing one of your pieces, as well
as vital space on the board.
But thinking two to three steps ahead, beating
your adversary’s moves before they’ve
even been made.
Now there’s a viable strategy.
Tricky, but viable; after all, if it was easy,
we’d all be Queen’s Gambit level chess
prodigies.
Eric Matthews had never been good at the game,
but he had a pretty substantial reason to
keep trying.
And that reason’s name was Brian Matthews,
his father.
You see, for as long as Eric could remember,
his dad had regarded a high level of skill
on the chessboard to be a sign of intellectual
superiority.
Intelligence was something that Brian put
quite a considerable value on, given that
he was a professor at a university in their
home county in England.
Some of Eric’s earliest memories were of
playing chess with his dad, usually on a Friday
night when Brian got home after a week of
giving lectures to the next generation of
scholars.
Obviously, with his son at such a young age,
the professor would take it easy on Eric,
playing in a much laxer fashion, focusing
instead on teaching the boy the basics of
the game.
And, for a time at least, it was good.
It was a rare time that Eric and his academic
father could spend bonding, after all, with
his mother gone, his dad was all he had.
But as the years passed, the game changed.
By the time Eric was a teenager, Brian had
stopped pulling his punches on the chessboard.
He had hoped his son would build on what he’d
learned when they played in the past, using
those skills to best his dad on the board.
But to Eric, playing chess had never been
about a purely educational experience; it
was more about spending time with his old
man.
Time after time, the young man’s pawns fell
prey to Brian’s expertly considered and
far more competitive moves.
Try as he might, Eric couldn’t best his
dad.
He tried his best, and never stopped putting
the effort into every game, but thinking too
hard about one possible plan of attack left
him wide open to a counter-strategy from the
professor.
Over and over again he landed himself in checkmate,
or made illegal moves without even realizing
it, every time earning criticism and chastisement
from his scholarly father.
Every game it got worse, it was like Eric
could feel his father’s gaze and the weighty
expectations behind it with each move he made
across the board.
There were so many nights where he wondered
if it would be better to give up entirely,
to knock down his own king and concede.
But how could he ever find any other shared
interests with his dad beyond the two of them
playing chess?
It had become a lifeline, tethering father
and son together, and to cut it now left Eric
uncertain if he’d sink or be able to swim
alongside Brian.
He had long admired his father, his achievements
in academia were impossible to avoid, with
more framed certificates hung up on the walls
than there were photos of the pair of them
together.
But the shadow it cast over him made Eric
desperate to keep this one shred of common
ground alive.
Eric wasn’t the type to give up, despite
how much of an uphill struggle the situation
felt like.
Taking a leaf out of his professor father’s
scholarly ways, he decided to learn the game
inside and out, every known move and strategy.
He would research the entire history of chess
itself, if that’s what it took to play with
the same skill as his dear old dad.
Over the coming weeks, Eric checked out every
book at his local library on the subject;
Beginner’s Guides, Advanced Rulebooks, and
even a few volumes on notable players throughout
the extensively long history of the game.
Along the way, a chapter of a certain book
stood out to Eric.
It described a chess prodigy from Russia,
who had created an early mechanical chess
device known as ‘The Samurai’.
It had been designed to be a traveling curiosity,
and would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating audience,
each one of them having forked over some of
their hard-earned money to watch this man-made
wonder.
The Russian chess prodigy’s young daughters
also had a love for the game.
Seeing that gave Eric a pang of jealousy,
wondering if those daughters had as much trouble
playing their own father as he did with Brian.
But at least there was an underlying shred
of hope there too, if this father and his
daughters could bond over chess, maybe there
was a chance for Eric and his dad too.
Sadly, it’s one thing to try and learn all
the facts you can about chess.
It’s an entirely different beast to put
all that information to use and apply it to
an actual game.
Despite having read every book he could get
his hands on, Eric still couldn’t best Brian
at the board.
It was like nothing had changed, his father
barely noticed when Eric tried to replicate
move sets he’d read up on, and still managed
to not only counter those moves but check
his queen in the process.
So, practice, Eric thought.
After all, practice was supposedly meant to
make perfect, right?
The plan was simple if he practiced his chess
moves enough times, and figured out how he
could call on what he’d learned, then he
might stand a chance at winning when he and
his dad played each other.
There was just one hiccup to the plan: Eric
needed someone to practice against.
The only other person in the house was Brian,
meaning it was that hiccup that turned into
a problem almost big enough to stop Eric in
his tracks.
That is, until he went into his father’s
lab.
It was under the house itself, a sort of sub-level,
maybe used as a basement or cellar by the
previous owners.
But since Professor Matthews and his son had
lived there, the entire room had been remodeled
into an at-home laboratory.
Not a terribly advanced one, of course, this
was the early nineties, after all.
A majority of Brian’s time, even when he
was at home instead of working at the university,
was spent on his own, downstairs in the lab.
Eric had gone down there in search of his
dad, to ask him if there was anyone whom he
knew who he could practice and develop his
chess skills with.
But, instead, what he found down there was
the last thing he expected to see.
Not that he had any clue exactly what it was,
at first.
The… thing was some kind of bizarre contraption,
a collection of components that didn’t seem
to be in any logical configuration.
However, it was primarily comprised of something
that Eric recognized all too well: a chess
table.
This one was metal, steel to be precise, and
seemed to be hooked up to some sort of computer.
While, back in the nineties, computers were
hardly as commonplace as they are now, Eric
had seen a fair few at school and the library.
Although this one was different, it seemed…
old.
Far older than Eric thought computers had
been around for; as far as he knew, they’d
only really come to prominence in the mid-eighties.
But this computer looked like it pre-dated
even that period.
Noticing another part of the contraption – a
large steam engine with the words ‘Manufactured
by Maudslay, Sons & Field, established 1840’
engraved on one side – made it seem that
this whole device had been around since the
Victorian era.
The next part that caught his eye was the
chess pieces themselves, each one standing
neatly in its place on the board.
They looked delicate, intricately carved from
some smooth substance.
For a moment, Eric toyed with the thought
of how they could even be made from bone,
noting how each pawn, knight, rook, bishop,
king and queen were all about the size of
a human finger bone.
He dismissed the idea; nobody would ever do
something like that.
Eric grabbed a sheet covering a larger component
hooked up to the mess.
Lifting it away in a swift pull, it unveiled
what was sitting beneath: a full suit of 18th
Century Samurai armor.
Eric looked closer at the embellishments on
the surface of the pauldrons; he was no expert
on Feudal Japan, but it looked authentic enough
to be the real thing, if not a very close
approximation.
Taking a look at the collection of oddities
all tethered together in his father’s lab,
a certain detail of all his chess research
came to the forefront of Eric’s mind.
The armor had given it away: this was ‘The
Samurai’ – or, at the very least, a least
a crude, homemade version of it that his dad
had put together.
But if it worked, it was also something to
practice against.
It didn’t take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption, trying to get it to
work.
All the while, the question of why his dad
owned such a thing kept drumming up noise
in the back of his head.
Had Brian built it, or was this the original
made by that Russian chess prodigy?
Was this machine the reason that Eric’s
dad possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess?
And would using it give him the edge he needed
to best him at the game and earn his father’s
respect?
After what felt like hours upon hours of trial
and error with a machine he could barely comprehend,
Eric seemed to have cracked it.
As far as he could tell, the steam engine
powered the whole contraption and could be
set to five different speeds, labeled on the
side in roman numerals.
The power from the engine was then fed to
some kind of sophisticated mechanism that
was within the suit of samurai armor, allowing
it to move, and what appeared to be a series
of electromagnets that moved the chess pieces
and kept them on the board.
Flicking it onto the third-highest of the
five speed levels, the machine whirred into
life; the sounds of creaking, and grinding
of metal filled the lab.
Kneeling opposite, Eric went to make the first
move…
only to stop himself.
It wasn’t that he’d changed his mind about
practicing against the Samurai, but because
of the speed he’d set it to.
Determining that the settings must have correlated
to difficulty levels, Eric figured that if
he really wanted to get the most rigorous
practice, to really hone his chess moves,
he needed to commit fully.
Reaching for the dial, he turned the device
up to its fifth and highest speed, then made
his first move.
He pushed one of the bone-colored pawns forward
by a single square and waited.
A split second passed, and the arm of the
early automaton responded with its first countermove.
It was quick, almost moving with the same
natural fluidity and speed as an actual human
being; albeit still with a little bit of creaking,
and some slight, clockwork-like stutters.
But it worked nonetheless, the machine could
play.
The tension over the first game was palpable,
forming a layer of sweat over Eric’s forehead.
Every whirr and tick of the machine gave the
impression they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves, adding to the
urgency.
Despite this, Eric Matthews tried his best
to stay calm.
This was practice after all, a dry run, not
the inevitable game he’d play against his
dad.
With every move he made, his heart drummed
against his ribs, uncertain he’d made the
right call.
Each time the robotic hand cruelly knocked
one of his pieces away, Eric felt the surge
of frustration, but told himself to quell
it.
He kept focused, used what he’d researched
to adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machine’s moves, until…
Checkmate.
He’d beaten it – he might have lost everything
save for a knight, a rook, his king and queen
– but he had won.
Trapped without anywhere else to move on the
board, the metal finger of the automaton conceded
the game, knocking over its own king in resignation.
Panting, heart racing from the sheer excitement
of being on the winning side of a game, Eric
hurriedly gathered up and reset all the pieces.
He had to go again, not just so he could be
certain it wasn’t a fluke, but to make sure
he had what it took to take on his professor
father.
Back and forth Eric went with the chess machine,
over and over again.
They were fairly evenly matched, it seemed.
Eric won the second game, only to be best
on the next two.
But it was some time afterward – he had
lost count of exactly how many rounds later
– that things started to change.
Maybe it was the age and condition of the
Victorian era chess computer, the natural
wear and tear stopping it from functioning
properly.
But Eric noticed the Samurai started to make
moves that were illogical, that practically
offered him the upper hand with no discardable
strategy behind them.
Then, its movements became flat-out illegal,
disregarding the directions and number of
squares each different piece was allowed to
move.
Before long, it was moving them erratically
around the chessboard, refusing to cooperate
and forcing Eric to call an end to the day’s
practicing.
Unfortunately, it wouldn’t be the end of
the unusual things that would happen that
day.
“Did you send me that weird email?”
was the first question Eric’s dad asked
him when he returned home, looking noticeably
under the weather.
Confused, Eric said he had no idea what his
father was talking about.
Professor Matthews then went on to describe
what he’d received on his work computer.
It had been an email, with a file attached
to it named ‘shakhmaty’, a word in Russian
that translates to ‘chess’.
Embedded in the email below – although it
had taken a long time to load being opened
on a 1990s computer – there had apparently
been a photo as well.
“It was rather odd, Eric,” Brian went
on.
“Quite unnerving to tell the truth.
Black and white, all sort of distorted and
stretched.
But it looked like two young girls, one grinning
and the other screaming.
I’ve been feeling…
well, not quite myself since I saw it.”
With that, Brian excused himself, stating
he’d been suffering from headaches and a
high temperature, and as a result, needed
to go and lay down.
It wasn’t like his father to get ill, Eric
thought, but of course, he had no reason to
assume it was anything serious.
Probably just a spate of fatigue after a long
day of teaching at the university, no cause
for concern.
If only that’s all it was.
Within a few hours, Brian was completely restless,
so unable to sleep that simply taking a nap
was impossible.
He kept calling to Eric, complaining of the
sound of childlike laughter coming from somewhere
in the house, but his son hadn’t heard anything.
By the time the sun went down, Eric was trying
to calm his dad down through a rush of intense
anxiety that gripped him.
Brian had claimed to be hallucinating, seeing
the warped faces of two girls that frightened
him half to death.
It was getting late, long past the time they
usually played chess together, but for now,
Eric’s mind was focused solely on helping
his dad.
For a while, he seemed to be able to calm
his father down, only to realize Brian wasn’t
settled at all.
He was awake, eyes open, fully conscious,
but wasn’t responding at all to Eric asking
if he was alright.
Instead, the accomplished academic just stared
blankly into space.
Eric had been up all night, exhausted, worried
for Brian’s safety, and completely clueless
about what was happening to him.
After a while of being non-responsive, his
dad seemed to regain a little bit of lucidity
once more, but his behavior was erratic.
“Take me back to work, I need to get on
my computer!”
Brian demanded of his son.
When Eric refused, that’s when his dad got
angry, and agitated.
Professor Brian Matthews was sadly found dead
within the next few months.
Several months later, as the sole executor
of his father’s estate and last living relative,
Eric had to be the one to go through his dad’s
personal belongings.
Volumes upon volumes of thick academic books,
his smart, scholarly clothes.
The house was almost clear now, save for one
thing that was left in the basement lab.
Flicking on the light switch, Eric looked
at the Samurai sitting motionless, still uncovered
after their last practice game.
He’d sold off the chess pieces to a collector
in New York, now it was just an empty oddity.
Eric placed a king on the board, one of the
ones that he and his dad had used when they
played each other.
With a gentle flick of his finger, he toppled
it, resigning to the strange automaton and
leaving it there in the laboratory.
He wasn’t sure how, but he had some kind
of gut feeling that this chess machine had
somehow been responsible for his father’s
fate.
Of course, Eric had no idea what the device
actually was, and what… or who lay beneath
its whirring metal parts.
SCP-1875 is the designation given to this
machine now, and has been ever since the Foundation
recovered it not long after Eric sold his
father’s house.
They were able to learn much more about it
than young Mr. Matthews, or even the late
Professor Matthews, ever had.
Not just how to make it work or what its function
was, but who had built it… and who had been
used to build it.
Although details of his real name eluded the
Foundation’s top researchers, they were
able to uncover newspaper articles about the
device from all over Russia, America, and
England, dating back to the early 1900s.
The Russian chess prodigy who’d invented
it and toured the chess-playing machine around,
had used some interesting components to make
his automaton.
Maybe they were where it derived its skill
at the game, and its apparent temperament
when the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long.
He had used his daughters to make the machine.
Deep within the heart of this early form of
computer, the two girls brain tissue had been
hooked up to the electromagnets.
The machine’s moves were theirs; each pawn
or rook shifting across the black and white
squares of the board, every rule or strategy
their prodigy father had taught, it all determined
how the device played.
Their minds, taken from their skulls, were
now the analytical engine of their father’s
creation.
The bones of their fingers, he'd carved into
chess pieces.
Over the coming weeks, the Foundation naturally
ran their usual slew of tests on SCP-1875,
playing multiple games of chess against it.
Every time, they increased the machine’s
five levels of speed, until it started behaving
erratically while on the highest setting.
Shortly after, every member of personnel working
on SCP-1875 received a bizarre email.
It contained a file, named with the Russian
word for chess…
And a photograph; of the stretched, distorted,
smiling, and screaming faces of two young
girls.
Faces that you might be seeing very soon…
‘You all know exactly who I am.’
The bald chemistry teacher looked around at
the men surrounding him in the desert.
Cadillacs, leather jackets, blacked-out shades.
The gang members shifted nervously from foot
to foot as the man bragged openly about what
he’s done to build his criminal empire.
Walter White’s attention turned back to
the man in front of him, a slight sneer played
around his lips.
‘Now, say my name.’
The man took a moment to reply as the desert
wind blew behind him.
He seemed to be weighing his options, realizing
quickly that he had lost all control over
the situation.
‘Heisenberg.’
‘You’re g-’
BANG!
Walter White fell to the ground dead.
The characters all around yelped in surprise,
drew their guns, and started wildly pointing
them around the circle, trying to figure out
who killed the great Heisenberg.
But his killer just stared in awe from his
couch in the front room as the Netflix show
kept playing on the TV.
Had the toy gun in his hand really done that?
*
Josh had admitted to himself that he had a
problem a long time ago.
But at least being a yard-sale addict was
cheaper than just a regular old retail addict.
Actually in truth, he was also an estate-sale
addict, a garage-sale addict and a thrift
store addict.
Anywhere you could buy people’s old junk
for rock-bottom prices, he’d sniff it out.
The Saturday that his life changed forever
was just like any other Saturday, really.
In the sweaty heat of the Atlantic City suburbs,
he hadn’t meant to stop by any sales today,
but one just so happened to catch his eye.
There was a box marked ‘Nerd Stuff’ and
he took that as a personal challenge.
Was this some old lady’s version of nerd
stuff or a veteran Dungeon Master’s treasure
trove?
The reality was somewhere in-between the two.
There were a couple of seasons of Buffy on
VHS, a copy of the original Deus Ex, and some
Legend of Zelda plushies.
It hadn’t really been worth stopping his
car for, except for a little plastic splash
of color that caught his eye.
Josh reached way down to the bottom of the
box and rooted around for it.
There was no way, it couldn’t possibly be
the toy he’d spent all his childhood asking
for and never getting.
But it was!
A 1985 Nintendo Entertainment System Zapper!
With an orange grip and barrel, NES gray bodywork,
and the beautiful font printed along the side,
it was unmistakable.
He threw a wad of cash at the old lady behind
the table and rushed back into his car, quickly
as he could.
It was time to cancel his day plans, he had
a childhood dream to fulfill!
But no sooner than he had got home and flipped
on his TV, the dream came crashing down around
him.
His old NES, the one he’d had since he was
a little kid, had sadly keeled over.
It refused to power on, no matter what he
did.
So that made his Zapper pretty much useless.
The best he could do with it now would be
to point it at the TV and make pew pew noises
with his mouth.
So Josh opened up Netflix and put on an episode
of Breaking Bad.
Little did he know, as he raised the Zapper
to the screen, that he was actually in possession
of SCP-674.
Nobody would know looking at it on the surface,
even the most hardcore gamers wouldn’t have
a clue, because you can fully disassemble,
clean, and reassemble the Zapper and get no
indication that it’s anything other than
what it appears to be.
However, as soon as the gun is pointed at
a television screen or a computer monitor
of any kind, it starts to pose a very real
threat.
Or, at least, a very real fictional threat.
If you shoot at the screen, whatever media
is playing on it at the time will react and
adapt to what has just happened.
That means characters on the screens will
react in accordance with the rules of their
respective universes.
In a grounded, realistic drama, the gunshot
will behave like any other, killing or wounding
the victim with perhaps enough time for them
to give a dying monologue, but in an episode
of Rick and Morty, the shot could manifest
in any number of bizarre creative ways.
News crews that witness the user shooting
a person in their live report will continue
to cover the incident as if it is part of
the ongoing story.
If you shoot Walter White, he falls to the
ground dead.
Josh stared at the screen in utter amazement.
He didn’t expect the writers to kill off
their main character just like that.
Wasn’t there supposed to be another 9 episodes?
What would they do to fill all that time?
As the episode played out, it seemed to mostly
just follow Jesse, trying desperately to escape
with his money before it was too late.
He kept glancing towards the camera for some
reason, with a slight look of fear in his
eyes.
Very strange creative decision there.
Josh backed out of the show to scroll through
his “continue watching.”
There was something a little creepy about
how he’d pointed that Zapper at the TV,
pulled the trigger, and perfectly, at that
moment, a character had been shot.
Time to pick out a show without any guns and
murder for a bit.
Something safe.
The familiar melodica tune filled the lounge
as various shots of Dunder Mifflin employees
busied themselves, shredding credit cards
and answering phone calls.
It never ceased to make his worries go away
seeing the words ‘The Office’ appear on
the screen.
He settled into the couch, watching as the
characters all gathered in the conference
room for some first-aid training.
The CPR dummy lay on the floor with Michael
Scott earnestly explaining to the woman that
the victim appeared to have lost their limbs.
He laughed along as the scene descended into
chaos, as none of the employees took the training
seriously at all.
Even though he’d seen this episode countless
times, it never got old.
Absent-mindedly, he pointed the gun at the
TV and pulled the trigger.
BANG!
Pam collapsed on the ground.
All of the characters dived out of the way,
trying to find cover behind their chairs,
not daring to peek out at the camera.
Only the first aid lady stayed on the scene,
trying her best to resuscitate Pam.
It cut to a shot of Dwight talking to the
camera sadly.
He said something that was almost funny, but
there was a real heaviness in the moment.
His eyes were red, like he’d been crying
off-camera.
Josh flipped the TV off and stared at himself
in the dark reflection.
Was he dreaming?
He hadn’t just done that… had he?
Fortunately for Josh and for the rest of humanity,
he had not killed Jenna Fisher or Bryan Cranston.
He hadn’t even killed their characters in
the shows, at least not for anyone other than
himself.
Research into SCP-674 shows that the appearance
of characters being killed off on screen only
exists in the mind of the shooter.
For everyone else, The Office remains the
same as it always was.
Unfortunately for Josh, however, Pam is now
dead in that universe and will always be whenever
he watches an episode.
It leaves a real shadow over the later seasons,
but the characters apparently manage to do
a good job pivoting into its new darker tone.
Other shows that have been tested in research
conditions have yielded interesting results.
Like in Star Trek, it is impossible to actually
kill Captain Kirk.
Instead, various red shirts always just so
happen to dive in front of him or fall into
frame at the pivotal moment.
With a small dead zone on the right-hand side
of the screen, characters who witness enough
shootings have the sense to stick to that
side of the frame whenever the shot is on
them, sometimes going so far as to plead directly
with the viewer, breaking the fourth wall
in their desperation to survive.
When Josh came back from a long walk outside,
he’d convinced himself that what he had
seen earlier was all just some vivid dream.
A dream he didn’t remember waking up from
but definitely wasn’t happening anymore.
He’d play some video games, that’s what
he’d do.
He had decided he would just play some Super
Smash Bros and unwind.
Anyone who has ever said that sentence to
themselves will know firsthand how foolish
that is.
Not ten minutes later, Josh had definitely
forgotten all about his dream from before.
He was too busy raging and cursing at the
screen.
He couldn’t stand playing against King Dedede,
that stupid hammer move always got him.
Without thinking, Josh snatched the Zapper
from the couch next to him and blasted Dedede
right in the face.
In classic Smash Bros style, the giant penguin
king was launched backwards, flying off the
screen in a blast of colorful smoke.
But he didn’t respawn.
For a second, his character just stood on
the screen awkwardly before it kicked him
back out to the character select screen.
This time though, King Dedede’s picture
was missing.
Josh couldn’t help himself.
He set up a free for all match straight away,
picking all of the characters he hated to
fight against.
Sonic, Mario, Pikachu, Bowser, Link, Nes,
even Wii Fit Trainer.
One after the other.
Bang bang bang!
He felt a strange sense of satisfaction once
he’d done his work.
Great, now the character list only had the
fair, balanced ones left.
They just so happened to all be his favorite
characters too.
But why stop there?
Josh jumped across to Elden Ring and marched
his knight up through the gate to Stormveil
Castle.
Before Margit had even gotten through his
opening cutscene, Josh had shot the boss right
in the face.
This boss battle that he’d been stuck on
for hours was over before it even started.
What else could he do now?
He put on an episode of Stranger Things and
shot the Demogorgon, then Moff Gideon in the
Mandalorian, and some goblins in Hogwarts
Legacy.
The clickers from the Last of Us took a couple
of extra shots but went down easy enough.
He went over to his PC and killed the Ender
Dragon in Minecraft without blowing up any
beds.
He won a game of Rocket League 53-0 after
he shot both cars on the opposing team.
He played through DOORS in Roblox without
a single jumpscare.
He’d just shoot any monster that filled
his screen.
What could be better?
He reckoned it was time for more movies.
Walking back across the lounge, spinning the
gun around his finger like a Western, he wondered
if now would be a good chance to hunt down
all the legendary animals in Red Dead 2.
It would certainly make the job a lot easier
if he could kill them all in just one shot.
He’d just need to be careful not to shoot
Arthur by accident.
But then Josh sat on the remote.
The TV flicked over to an old rerun of Bob
Ross just as he’d been squaring up to shoot.
He pulled the trigger before he could react.
The canvas was spattered red.
From somewhere off-camera he heard the artist’s
wheezing voice try to comfort him.
‘There are no mistakes, just happy…’
But he died before he could say another word.
*
The Exposition Gun first came onto the SCP
Foundation’s radar when a strange police
report was doing the rounds on an email chain
amongst local authorities.
They were all finding a great deal of value
from a man called Josh, who had turned himself
in at his local station in Atlantic City for
‘killing like everyone’.
Naturally, the police took his report very
seriously, for all of about 10 minutes.
As soon as they realized that he was talking
about video games, TV, and movie characters,
the whole case turned into one big joke.
They sat Josh down in front of a TV and played
him episodes of the shows he was talking about,
pointing out characters still alive in scenes
after he’d supposedly shot them to death,
but he seemed to just grow more distressed
as he realized he was experiencing this phenomenon
alone.
By the time, Foundation agents tracked Josh
down and took him in for questioning, the
gun had moved on.
He’d marched it straight back to the old
lady who’d sold it to him, who had then
sold it on again.
Josh’s full account of events and description
of the Zapper were taken before he was administered
Class C amnestics and allowed to continue
with his yard-sale addiction uninhibited.
SCP-674 was found some time later in the possession
of a 33-year-old Caucasian male simply referred
to as Mr S. A reclusive man in a neighboring
city, Mr S first gained the SCP Foundation's
attention through his extremist political
blog, in which he claimed to have assassinated
prominent political figures, news anchors,
and talk show hosts.
While the truth of those claims was demonstrably
false, it was clear from the way he described
events that he really did believe the delusion.
After being questioned, it was discovered
that he had never left his home.
Instead, he stayed on his couch, watching
news reports and firing at any prominent figures
that appeared, believing that he was indeed
killing them in the real world.
Despite claiming that he was using SCP-674
to prevent a military police state, using
the device to "assassinate" so many high-profile
figures had the opposite effect on his video
reality.
In his blog posts, he described an increasingly
unstable global order, martial law, and catastrophic
events consistent with the hypothetical release
of two deadly SCPs.
His house was barricaded, with security cameras
set up in every direction.
The more he had been using the gun, the more
the characters and journalists on TV had threatened
him, claiming that the SCP Foundation were
on their way to apprehend him and that he
would face retribution for what he had been
doing.
Mr S’s intended ambush of Foundation agents
failed.
While they appeared to be dying on the security
feeds he had set up, the agents experienced
no physical harm in reality as they apprehended
the man and seized SCP-674.
While the majority of researchers have deemed
that SCP-674 is harmless to all but the mental
well-being of the shooter, there was a notably
sinister result to Mr S’s time in Foundation
detention.
Alone in his cell, Mr S soon started to engage
in heated arguments with the security camera
set up to monitor him.
There is no record of any voices in the room
other than his own, yet he seemed to be locked
in a fierce argument.
All of a sudden, Mr S dropped to the ground
dead with three .38 caliber handgun bullets
lodged in his chest.
The entirety of his holding cell was searched
for evidence of a shooter, but none was found.
The Exposition Gun remains in a locked plastic
case in Storage Site 23.
Aside from regular cleaning and maintenance,
it is used under controlled circumstances
to creatively gather intelligence about further
SCP activity.
In the event of the site being compromised,
personnel are allowed to destroy the Exposition
Gun at their own discretion, should it fall
into the wrong hands.
Rock.
Paper.
Scissors.
A simple hand game dating back to the Han
Dynasty of Imperial China.
It is a decisive game between two players,
with the only outcomes being win, lose, or
draw.
We’re quite familiar with the Rock-Paper-Scissors
here at the SCP Foundation,
as the guards are often seen playing intense
rounds of the game to determine
who will be the unlucky soul chosen to secure
one of various keter-class SCPs during a given
week.
In most cases, this use of Rock-Paper-Scissors
is accepted as a largely harmless and fair
way for defensive personnel to arrange their
shifts.
The reason for this is that the results of
Rock-Paper-Scissors are generally random,
as there are very few ways for an individual’s
skill to influence the game.
Or so one might think.
In reality, Rock-Paper-Scissors is a deeply
psychological game,
and this is mainly because of its origin as
a contest between fellow human beings.
The average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns,
and with only three options to keep track
of,
it is entirely possible for a seasoned veteran
of rock-paper-scissors to predict their opponent’s
choice before any hands are thrown.
Of course, that opponent may also commit an
error of their own, by misreading the other
player’s actions,
and thus there is always a chance for an impulsive
decision to swing the results of the game
in either direction.
Human limitation is the only skill-based mechanic
in the game of Rock-Paper-Scissors,
and that same limitation is what - in the
eyes of some - holds the game back from reaching
its true potential.
That was the case, until someone out there
discovered the rules to an anomalous version
of Rock-Paper-Scissors being spread through
a mysterious email.
While all attempts to trace the email back
to its original sender have left the Foundation
with more questions than answers,
we have been able to learn more about the
differences between the rules of standard
Rock-Paper-Scissors and the anomalous version.
We have given this anomalous version of Rock-Paper-Scissors
the designation SCP-4633, and unlike the classic
edition
- under no circumstances are any Foundation
personnel allowed to play a game incorporating
any of the alternative rules.
While the ceiling for skill and variety is
theoretically much higher in a Rock-Paper-Scissors
match featuring SCP-4633,
the risks to the players far outweigh any
added novelty.
Here is how SCP-4633 functions during an average
game of Rock-Paper-Scissors…
well, average prior to the anomalous properties
taking effect:
rather than being limited to using merely
rock, paper, or scissors - as the name of
the game implies
- the players gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures
which upon the act of being thrown become
seamlessly integrated into both players’
shared understanding of the rules.
This alone would be bizarre enough, but the
true harm caused by SCP-4633 is in the nature
of the gestures themselves.
When one of the non-standard gestures allowed
by SCP-4633 is used,
the players’ hands will change shape in
ways that, under normal circumstances, would
be anatomically impossible.
Each of these non-standard gestures is distinct
from the next,
with the only commonality being an unusual
tendency for the final gesture to resemble
biological structures often seen in sea life.
One particular gesture might cause a player
to rapidly grow a ring of additional fingers
surrounding a gaping anemone-like mouth in
the palm,
while another could result in the player’s
entire arm flattening into a fin-like appendage.
Regardless of how severe a departure from
a typical human limb the final gesture would
be,
the limbs – and on rare occasions, the entire
body – of the player using the gesture will
quickly and irreversibly mutate into the shape
required to successfully perform it.
While these gestures overwhelmingly result
in forms that would be distressing to most
people,
the same cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the rules
also appears to apply to the changes affecting
their own bodies.
To the players of an SCP-4633-augmented match
of Rock-Paper-Scissors, the nonstandard gestures
seem as mundane as the original three.
Unfortunately, the morphic properties of SCP-4633
are practically irreversible,
with extreme reconstructive surgery being
required in even the best of cases.
In all instances of SCP-4633, surgical intervention
is necessary to prevent the spread of details
regarding the non-standard gestures and their
usage.
Because of the immediate shift in cognitive
awareness among participants, all that is
needed for a new instance of SCP-4633 to occur
is the faintest hint of knowledge of the alternative
rules.
It’s even been noted that between different
groups of players,
the non-standard gestures can vary heavily
or seemingly be created on the fly as the
desire to win at all costs takes hold.
Here are a few examples of anomalous gestures
which have been observed during instances
SCP-4633.
The list is by no means comprehensive,
but it will provide an insight into how SCP-4633
drastically alters the existing mechanics
of the game
as well as the physique of the players.
The “Thu-ry-leh” gesture transforms the
user’s fingers into barbed tentacles.
It beats paper and scissors, but loses to
rock.
“Cha-voo-aga” folds the fingers of the
hand into the palm and causes them to emerge
through the back of the palm.
It allows the user to throw a second gesture
after they’ve seen their opponent’s choice.
“Aj-kel-haz” splits the hand into a pair
of poisonous stingers which also produce a
potent electrical current between them.
It has been seen to lose to paper, but seemingly
of their own will,
the stingers lashed at the opposing player
and caused them to fall unconscious three
rounds later due to the effects of the poison.
“Sha-ooh-sa” beats paper and two other
anomalous gestures; loses to scissors, rock
and a third gesture
and morphs the user’s arm into a dactyl
club similar to the front appendages of a
mantis shrimp.
“Iz-urg-av” simply causes the player to
grow three additional thumbs on one hand.
The final gesture resembles a triple thumbs
up.
Iz-urg-av has not been seen to beat any gestures,
and the player who uses it always seems to
go on to lose the match.
“Pag-ak-mar” causes the middle and ringer
to recede into the hand,
while the pointer and pinky fingers extend
to resemble the eye stocks of a snail or slug.
The rest of the hand also becomes coated in
a thin layer of slime which continues to secrete
from within.
Pag-ak-mar beats scissors and paper, but loses
to rock and another anomalous gesture known
as “vah-yan-jek.”
Incidentally, vah-yan-jek causes the arm of
the player using it to elongate into a worm-like
tube that periodically spews a gout of salt
water on the opponent.
When vah-yan-jek was seen beating pag-ak-mar,
the salt water appeared to have some adverse
effect on the latter gesture,
causing the eyestalks to droop and the hand
to shrivel until it was half its original
size.
Another anomalous gesture is “gra-zath-rog”
recognized by the skin, muscle, and veins
of the hand turning translucent,
revealing a pulsing red organ in the interior
of the palm.
Once gra-zath-rag has been thrown, the player
who used it may call out the name of one other
gesture,
which can no longer be used in the current
match.
The “uka-yag” gesture is a bit deceptive,
as it resembles rock when first thrown, but
gradually causes the hand to condense into
a lump of inert material
not dissimilar to actual igneous rock.
The knuckles as well begin to exude a superheated
mineral substance similar to molten lava.
Uka-yag exclusively beats paper and appears
to lose to everything else.
Many of the gestures on record have no known
name,
but their function within SCP-4633’s altered
rules is clear from the context in which they
were used.
Such is the case with one anomalous gesture,
which caused most of the player’s hand to
withdraw into a siphon-like opening at their
wrist
before the very same orifice shot a stream
of ink into the opposing player’s eyes.
While there was no lasting harm done to the
opponent by this gesture,
the ink did cause temporary blindness,
which persisted until they were defeated by
way of their rock losing to paper.
Another unknown gesture has been seen beating
both iz-urg-av and uka-yag.
This gesture makes the player’s hand resemble
the crest and gas-filled body of a pacific
man-o-war.
These examples are only scraping the surface
of the seemingly endless possibilities that
SCP-4633 has to offer.
As you can see, the anomalous hand gestures
can be just as dangerous within the game itself
as the permanent changes they invoke in the
user.
While the Foundation has done its best to
contain all information surrounding SCP-4633,
there have been clear efforts by several unknown
groups to push the game into continued usage.
Over the past three decades, instances of
SCP-4633 have seen increasing popularity in
the world of high-stakes gambling.
Perhaps it is because of the inherent thrill
of watching two opponents trying to strategically
outwit each other
with a countless number of non-standard gestures,
but more likely, it is part of the anomalous
effects of SCP-4633 that the game would appeal
to those desperate to risk everything
on a slim chance of victory.
This neatly brings us to the SCP-4633-related
incident which occurred aboard the private
ocean liner known as the SS Fateful Emma.
Before the incident, the Fateful Emma would
sail into international waters twice a year.
Each time it would bring along a new group
of passengers,
seemingly selected from the underprivileged
and downcast sector of society.
A great many of these passengers were convicts
with repeat violent offenses chosen from supermax
facilities the world over.
The process by which these inmates were chosen
for a voyage aboard the ship was not dissimilar
from the methods the Foundation uses to acquire
new Class-D Personnel.
Naturally, this was how the research team
was able to be tipped off about the Fateful
Emma.
It became apparent soon after looking into
the ship’s career that individuals altered
by the effects of SCP-4633 had been seen departing
from the ship on multiple occasions in remote
island harbors.
Most of the time, the individuals would also
be - to the best of their ability with their
metamorphosed forms
- carrying briefcases filled with hundreds
of thousands of dollars in cash.
While witnesses tended to write off the strange
appearances of those affected as being the
result of deformity or injury
– or in more pronounced instances dismissing
the encounters as sightings of creatures from
the local mythology
– it was clear to anyone familiar with SCP-4633
what was truly going on.
These passengers were being made to play pitched
games of Rock-Paper-Scissors featuring SCP-4633
for massive sums of wealth, and what was worse:
the grand prize winners were seemingly being
released back into civilization without the
knowledge of law enforcement.
Of course, what the Foundation was most concerned
about was the potential for a large-scale
leak of detailed information involving SCP-4633.
It seemed that the Foundation’s latest faceless
enemy had revealed itself.
Whatever wealthy group of individuals was
pulling the strings behind the games aboard
the SS Fateful Emma,
it was very likely that the ship was also
well-protected by a private army of trained
mercenaries.
In a display of swift but necessary initiative,
The Foundation assembled a brand new Mobile
Task Force to be dispatched onto the ocean
liner:
Mobile Task Rho-52 with the fitting codename
“Rochambeau.”
The mobile task force would board the vessel
secretly,
and use whatever means necessary to prevent
the spread of SCP-4633
and any evidence of the associated non-standard
hand gestures.
Before the Fateful Emma’s next voyage, the
Foundation isolated the port where it would
depart from and made sure that the MTF agents
were in position.
The operation was co-captained by Agent Dubois
and Agent Zheng,
both of whom prided themselves on having extraordinary
good luck.
Agent Dubois would stealthily move the majority
of the agents under his command into the cargo
hold below deck,
and await Agent Zheng’ signal.
Agent Zheng himself would assume the name
and identity of one of the criminal passengers,
who was intercepted before boarding by the
mobile task force.
The would-be participant was subsequently
detained and brought into the Foundation as
a Class-D personnel.
As the SS Fateful Emma began to leave the
harbor,
Agent Zheng joined the other passengers who
had been gathered together in an enormous
function hall.
There was little indication of when the games
would begin, and Zheng made an effort to keep
a low profile until more information was available.
Shortly after the ship had officially arrived
in international waters,
an eccentric man entered the room on a walkway
that overlooked the rest of the passengers.
He was flanked by a pair of armed bodyguards.
It was plain from the man’s style of dress
and demeanor that he was both absurdly wealthy
and completely out of his mind.
He wore a pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of a
Siberian tiger.
A pair of dark shades with sequined rims obscured
his eyes from view,
but by far the strangest aspect of the rich
man’s was the fact that emerging from the
wrist of his right arm
was the eyeless head of a moray eel where
his hand should be.
The man spoke, addressing the entire room:
“Welcome, passengers new and old, to the
SS Fateful Emma!
While you are aboard this ship, your fate
is in your own hands.
Over the next twenty-four hours, you will
have the rare opportunity to play the greatest
game of chance that humanity has ever known!
Generations of people from every continent
and every walk of life have given their all
to the mastery of rock-paper-scissors-ack-rah-nos-vaf-lyl-tog-char-sth...”
The man proceeded to speak unusual syllables
for the next minute straight without even
a pause for breath.
In his report, Agent Zheng described the man’s
voice as gaining an increasingly loud hum
as his speech continued and that some of the
syllables didn’t seem to be the product
of human vocal cords.
He soon concluded his string of gibberish
and resumed speaking intelligible language:
“As is customary, we will be utilizing the
ill-gesh-toe-eee rules.
You will begin by selecting a single opponent
and challenging them to a best two of three
match.
This is a single elimination tournament, and
any competitors who cannot otherwise continue
to engage in matches will also be eliminated.
By the end of your time here, the luckiest
among you will be named the undisputed champion
of these games and will be granted unlimited
freedom along with the cash prize!
The rest of you will have to determine your
own fates, for you all know what awaits you
below.
May your hands be ready, your minds be sharp,
and remember… winning is everything!”
With a flourish of his moray eel hand, the
wealthy man finished his introductions and
promptly exited the room.
Agent Zheng looked at the passengers surrounding
him and saw that they were already beginning
to play rock-paper-scissors with each other.
A few had already begun using the anomalous
gestures, warping their limbs into hideous
sub-nautical shapes.
Agent Zheng gave the signal to Agent Dubois
and the rest of the mobile task force to begin
the operation.
Their target was primarily the moray-handed
man,
as well as any other close associates that
he had on board.
They would capture him alive and interrogate
him into revealing the mystery behind this
illegal gambling ring.
Once the mercenaries were dealt with, Agent
Dubois’ team would commandeer the ocean
liner and navigate it to SCP Foundation Research
Site 45 to await further orders.
As for Agent Zheng, he knew what he had to
do.
To buy time, he would participate in the ensuing
rock-paper-scissors tournament and eliminate
as many of the other players as possible.
This, he believed, was the best way to minimize
the number of anomalous gestures that would
be used aboard the ship.
Of course, he himself wouldn’t be using
any of the anomalous gestures either - opting
to limit himself to the standard three.
This could put him at a severe disadvantage
over the course of the competition, but Agent
Zheng knew better than to tempt fate.
Still, being eliminated seemed like something
he may want to avoid.
Even though the consequences for elimination
were left vague in the strange rich man’s
speech,
he still didn’t feel that it would be wise
to put himself in a compromised position while
aboard the Fateful Emma.
Bracing himself for the worst, Agent Zheng
accepted the challenge of a nearby passenger.
He was off to a promising start when he threw
a scissors hand against his opponent’s paper.
Because the matches were best two out of three,
all he needed was to win one of the next two
matches, and he’d have survived this round.
Then he saw the devious look on his opponent’s
face, and he knew that this match was about
to get weird.
Rather than admit defeat, Agent Zheng prepared
to throw scissors again.
The two challenged their hands, and just as
Zheng had feared, his opponent threw an anomalous
gesture.
Almost instantly, the opponent’s hand took
on a multi-mouthed piscine form
which began to spit sharp teeth in Agent Zheng’s
direction.
Fortunately, the agent’s bulletproof vest
was able to withstand the impact of the teeth.
What was even more fortunate was the fact
that the opponent seemed to be a good sport.
“Scissors beats Az-rah-vok.
You win,” said the other passenger before
walking away in search of their next match.
Curiously, the passenger’s transformed arm
continued to fire teeth across the room at
random intervals,
occasionally hitting and causing injury to
one of the other competitors.
Agent Zheng was grateful that the body armor
he was wearing had been tested to withstand
rapid fire from SCP-127.
Compared to the raw power of the living gun,
the teeth launched from the “Az-rah-vok”
gesture were practically BB rounds.
He had succeeded in not being eliminated,
both from the game and generally.
Excited about his win, Zheng sought out another
opponent to test his luck.
Below deck, Agent Dubois and the rest of the
mobile task force had just finished facing
off against some of the hired mercenaries
when they entered a room presumed to be the
liner’s sick bay.
Inside was a grisly sight: a second rock-paper-scissors
tournament playing out between players
that had been so thoroughly transformed by
the anomalous gestures of SCP-4633
that they barely appeared to still be human.
It was like a scene from a deep sea documentary,
with strange and unknowable creatures vying
for dominance
- not within a natural food chain or competition
for resources but within a seemingly never-ending
struggle to win a game of chance.
It was purgatory.
Rock-paper-scissors-purgatory.
Agent Dubois was appalled, but he knew better
than to attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all distracted.
The moray-handed man was still somewhere in
the ship, and capturing him was far more important.
The research team would decide what to do
with these former humans once the entire ship
was secure within the Foundation’s custody.
However, what Agent Dubois didn’t realize
is that some of these creatures were advancing
on his team.
In nightmarish and unearthly voices, they
chanted:
“Rock… rock… paper…
scissors…”
Suddenly, one of the abominations - who resembled
nothing more closely than an enormous mass
of coral
- produced four arms from within its body
and began to throw anomalous hand signs toward
the agents.
One of the arms threw “uka-yag”, which
coated an unsuspecting agent in hot lava,
causing him to drop to the floor in pain.
Panicked, Dubois ordered the task force to
eliminate every living thing in the sick bay
- although not in the sense of their tournament
standing, of course.
Meanwhile, Agent Zheng was on a win streak
in the function hall.
Through sheer luck and determination had managed
to avoid elimination while eliminating several
other passengers himself.
He began to notice that those who were eliminated
were quietly escorted away by the bouncers,
seemingly to have their anomalous changes
treated.
Now it was down to only twelve remaining passengers.
Agent Zheng knew that it was only a matter
of time before Dubois and his team took control
of the ship
but feeling reckless, he challenged one of
the remaining passengers.
In that moment, something came over him, as
if his determination to see the mission through
was also compelling him to win at any cost.
His opponent threw pag-ak-mar,
and out of instinct Zheng threw vah-yan-jek.
The agent went on to win the entire tournament,
but sadly, he was unable to collect the prize
money,
as during the skirmish below deck, the man
with the moray hand had escaped with the small
fortune in a high-speed submersible.
His ultimate goals and the scope of the shadowy
group he represented would remain unanswered
for the time being.
When the SS Fateful Emma finally arrived at
Site 45,
Agent Zheng came to his senses and realized
that he had underestimated the cognitive side-effects
of SCP-4633.
Due to the immediately recognizable anomalous
state of both of his arms, Agent Zheng was
later contained on a site with minimal security.
It is believed that researchers are still
searching for a method to reverse the effects.
It just goes to show that winning isn’t
everything.
The thin, pale humanoid anomaly had just found
itself… in Minecraft, of all places.
The all too familiar wail of emergency alarms
rang out through the corridors of the Foundation
facility.
It had happened again, another containment
breach.
Of course, the on-site personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a situation
like this, so well-versed in what to do during
an emergency that it had become second nature.
Whether they were research staff evacuating
for their own safety, or security teams moving
in to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control, everyone was
moving like they had been programmed, muscle
memory taking over.
The loose anomaly was none other than SCP-096,
all Foundation personnel were alerted and
reminded not to look directly at the creature.
There was just one problem: they couldn’t
look even if they’d ignored their order
to try.
Nobody could… because the Shy Guy was nowhere
to be found.
Well, nowhere in the real world, at least.
This whole situation – bizarre even by the
Foundation’s standards – had all started
with an experiment involving a member of the
disposable D Class Personnel.
Yet another dangerous convict severing one
of several life sentences, now being used
as an expendable human lab rat for the Foundation’s
often sinister purposes.
The experiment in question was an attempt
to further test the limitations of SCP-096’s
abilities.
By now, the Foundation had done extensive
research into the creature known as the Shy
Guy.
They knew its particular brand of anomalous
qualities were triggered when anyone looked
directly at it.
Being observed would instantaneously send
SCP-096 into an uncontrollable rage state,
causing it to pursue its observer until they
were no longer standing.
SCP-096 was known to be able to travel at
speeds so relentless it was pretty much possible
to stop.
One moment it was sobbing and screeching in
its cell having just been observed, and minutes
later, the wide-jawed, long-limbed monster
was standing behind whoever had seen it, making
its screaming face the image its victim took
to the grave with them.
Foundation researchers knew that SCP-096’s
rage state could be triggered by as little
as someone seeing the slightest hint of a
creature.
Even if the Shy Guy had been captured as a
tiny speck in the background of a photograph,
it would come after anyone whose eyes so much
as glanced over that speck.
It also didn’t matter how far away the observer
was – SCP-096 couldn’t be outrun, it could
track down anyone wherever they were in the
world.
But what if a person who had observed the
Shy Guy was no longer in the world…
The experiment had taken a lot of trial and
error – after all, digitizing a human being
and transforming their entire consciousness
into code was no easy task.
But the Foundation wasn’t above breaking
more than a few eggs to make an omelette,
especially when those eggs were the brains
of a few D Class Personnel.
Actually, the first test subjects turned out
more scrambled or fried, certainly overdone,
given the amount of smoke coming from their
ears.
But eventually, the research team had perfected
the device they had dubbed the ‘Neural Harness’,
a headset that could translate a person’s
mind into pure digital code.
Their consciousness would be extracted from
their body, leaving their physical form an
empty shell while a digital copy of them was
able to traverse the local on-site computer
network.
Of course, the Foundation wasn’t about to
let a digitized D Class run amok with their
systems, so their coding experts wrote a number
of specialized parameters into their successful
test subject.
Now, the digital D Class could be programmed
to follow the Foundation’s directive.
From his perspective, it was like he was floating
through cyberspace, towards the system the
Foundation had directed him too: a surveillance
camera inside SCP-096’s cell that usually
remained inactive.
But not today.
The camera blinked to life as soon as the
D Class’s code-based consciousness reached
it, and through it, he was able to observe
SCP-096, sitting against the far wall of its
containment chamber, gently whimpering and
rocking back and forth.
That is, until the creature felt that familiar
sensation of being watched.
It stood up, enraged, wailing uncontrollably
as the D Class watched from within the camera.
Then, a split second later, SCP-096 appeared
to blink out of existence.
It hadn’t worked, the experiment had failed,
and the digital D Class began to panic.
Before the Foundation’s coders could stop
him, he frantically scoured the local network
for anything, some kind of escape route back
into the real world.
Maybe, he thought, if he could get back into
his body, it wouldn’t count?
Technically, his digital self was separate
from his physical form, so he might get out
of SCP-096’s clutches on a technicality.
But it was impossible, his body was already
burned out by the Neural Harness, there was
no way for the D Class to transfer himself
back.
There was only one option left: hide.
And, as it turned out, someone had forgotten
to uninstall a certain building game from
a computer in one of the Foundation doctor’s
offices.
The D Class’s digitized mind zapped him
into Minecraft; from his point of view, it
was just like he existed within the game itself.
He did a computerized equivalent of breathing
a sigh of relief, only to take back all those
ones and zeros in a horrified gasp as he noticed
a tall, wiry-framed figure before him.
It hadn’t worked, SCP-096 had still managed
to follow him into Minecraft.
Even in a world of computer code, the Shy
Guy was able to dispatch its digital observer
quite easily, and what had once been a living
human mind in the form of binary code was
quickly deleted.
But that’s when SCP-096 started to take
notice of its surroundings.
With the most recent person to see it gone,
it had a chance to actually take in where
it was.
The bright rays of warm light coming down
from a cube-shaped sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around, constructed entirely
from cubes.
It fascinated SCP-096, instilling a kind of
childlike wonder in the Shy Guy the likes
of which it hadn’t experienced since…
well, since it couldn’t remember when.
Rather than leaving, instantly reappearing
in its containment chamber, SCP-096 made the
conscious decision to start exploring.
There was a mountainous biome surrounding
SCP-096, stony spires reaching up towards
a clear sky, with a waterfall cascading its
way down the nearest of them.
At the foot of one of the mountains was the
opening to a cave, which the Shy Guy found
itself wandering towards.
The light from the sun, while a pleasant and
welcome change to the surroundings it was
used to, was a little harsh on SCP-096’s
sunken eyes.
So, instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves, not unlike
the usual darkness of its containment chamber
back at the Foundation.
Traversing through long, winding corridors
of stone, SCP-096 found itself having to bend
down, to avoid hitting its head on the cave’s
low ceiling – obviously, this formation
of rocky blocks hadn’t formed with someone
of the Shy Guy’s height in mind.
There was a low, warm glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel, and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer, despite
the stone walls around it feeling like a tighter
confinement than its cell.
Approaching the source of the light, SCP-096
was relieved that the cave opened out into
a more spacious area, the cramped tunnel giving
way to an expansive chamber that lay within
the heart of the mountain.
The warm, orangey glow had been coming from
a flowing stream of boiling hot lava, that
seemed to trickle down from somewhere above,
creating a deadly, fiery pool directly in
the Shy Guy’s path.
But just before it could turn back and leave
the cave through the way he came, SCP-096
sensed that familiar feeling of something
observing him.
Across the lava pool, on the other side, was
a creature comprised of a green cube for a
head, with a long, armless cuboid body, and
four cubed feet.
If it had been present in the real world,
it might have been made out of leaves, like
a living shrub.
It was staring directly at the Shy Guy from
across the lava, only for this strange newcomer
to disappear a moment later.
The Creeper hissed, before it realized that
SCP-096 had leaped up behind it to land a
fatal blow.
But little did the infamously anxious anomaly
realize the sentient shrub wasn’t done.
There was a colossal boom that caused SCP-096
to stagger backwards, whimpering at the sudden
loud explosion and the pain that had accompanied
it.
The Creeper had blown itself to pieces, but
in doing so, had left a lasting injury, that
caused SCP-096 considerable discomfort as
it began limping towards the cave that led
out the opposite side of the mountain.
Despite its injury, the Shy Guy was still
able to move with relative ease, and the further
it went, the more it seemed to gradually heal.
However, it was as it stepped out once more
into the sunlight that the creature realized
just how hungry it was.
Back in the real world, it hadn’t eaten
for several hours, and surprisingly – even
while accidentally stuck in digitized form
– the hunger mechanics of Minecraft were
having an effect on SCP-096.
The Shy Guy started searching around for anything
that could prove to satiate its hunger.
There was a grove of trees not far, so SCP-096
lumbered closer to take a closer look.
It couldn’t be certain, but it felt there
was at least a slim chance that there were
apples growing among the leaves.
But even at the anomaly’s own elongated
height, it couldn’t simply reach up to pick
them.
However, it was while swiping its arms up
at the tree that the Shy Guy swung its fist
and knocked the tree trunk.
To the creature’s surprise, it was able
to chip away at the wood with its hands, punching
at the tree until the trunk had been reduced
to a collection of wooden blocks that the
Shy Guy was able to collect.
And sure enough, some red apples dropped from
the leaves above, enough to quell the hunger
that SCP-096 was feeling, at least for the
time being.
Nearby, something was moving through the trees.
It was yet to lock eyes on SCP-096, but the
second it did, the mob would surely have sealed
its own fate.
As it moved around, minding its own business,
the tall figure overheard the sounds of the
Shy Guy eating, and its attention was drawn
to where the creature was standing, enjoying
an apple.
Sensing it had been seen, SCP-096 turned and
locked eyes with the entity.
It was perhaps the only other being in Minecraft
that was a similar height and stature to the
anomaly itself – in fact, the pair were
strikingly similar.
Before SCP-096 could carry out its usual method
of attack, the Enderman suddenly teleported
out of view.
But it was too late now, both it and the Shy
Guy had looked at the other’s face; both
had been provoked, and were compelled to react
in exactly the same way.
Just as SCP-096 entered its rage state, the
Enderman too opened its mouth and began to
shake, making loud, lengthy sounds not dissimilar
to the Shy Guy’s own angered screams.
But something profoundly strange happened
next.
SCP-096 and the Enderman kept attempting to
pursue one another, appearing in a new location
within the Minecraft world, neither one getting
close enough to the other.
They’d teleport, only for the other to teleport
away the moment they saw each other, each
trying to catch one another but always staying
one step ahead or behind.
This rapid chase almost became a strange,
ongoing sort of teleporting dance between
SCP-096 and the Enderman.
At first, the Shy Guy had been compelled to
attack the Enderman, like it was with any
who looked directly at it.
But as they appeared and disappeared from
place to place, the creature started to feel
an odd kinship with this shadowy fellow.
It was so used to being frightened and alone,
to its overwhelming feelings of insecurity
and self-loathing, that the simplicity of
just traversing the open world – with a
creature very alike itself in many ways – it
had all come as a welcome change.
SCP-096 found it therapeutic even, and before
long, was following the Enderman not out of
any intention to do it harm, but just to feel,
for a while, like it had a friend.
Just a little bit longer, SCP-096 thought,
welcoming the enjoyment it felt playing this
game of Minecraft.